professional and we're in a beach house
oh well i guess if you have to be
stranded maybe that's not such a bad
place to be stranded
i think it would be my number one choice
oh good well
it's a new wind that blows no one any
good well said well said
thank you so much for doing this well
thank you for
thank you for being patient i know we've
put you off for a long time
that couldn't be helped but i'm very i'm
actually very happy to be doing this and
uh
i was weirdly enough i didn't expect it
but i was
looking forward to it really i wasn't
sure what how you would feel about it is
there an element of trepidation
or well definitely there's an element of
representation because
i would say the most stressful
experiences i've had in the last five
years
apart from being in the epicenter of
various demonstrations were definitely
interviews with people who were
well they ranged from mildly hostile to
very hostile and
those are tight ropes you know because
if you make a mistake
well it can be devastating and
devastating to your career devastating
to your family devastating to your rep
your general reputation so
i i think most people watching you
thought that was thought that you are
completely fearless kind of cool as a
cucumber unfazed by any amount of
attacks
yeah that's wrong that's wrong okay oh
yeah that's that's definitely
wrong um no
i i definitely found the interviews of
all the things i did
as i said apart from the demonstrations
you know how
being having your name being cursed out
and being chanted at by
several hundred angry people is not
anyone's idea of fun
especially if the attack continues
afterwards which happened on multiple
occasions and
but but i don't think that was worse
than
[Music]
the the more hostile interviews i i
really don't like upsetting people
[Applause]
well i am a clinical psychologist it's
not really it's my nature to help people
i would say um you know i
i i have a hierarchy of of belief in
some sense i'm not going to say
things i don't believe to be true to
spare anyone's feelings
although i would pick a truth that
spared
feelings the maximal allowable amount if
i
if i could do that so but
i'm not interested in generating
controversy
mostly i'm see it's a funny thing
because i've learned over the years and
this is again
in large part because i'm a clinical
psychologist is that
a little conflict in the present can
save an awful lot of catastrophe later
and people are very much likely to
sidestep a problem
in the hopes that it will go away and i
know the problems don't go away
they never go away what they do is they
multiply they fester and multiply and so
i will have the fight now
knowing that it's inevitable later and i
mean i
always conducted myself that way within
our family as michaela can attest to
both tammy and i never allowed anything
to sit
unspoken under the rug and so we'd have
our uncomfortable conversations but you
know i'd sweat my way through them i
don't
enjoy them by any stretch of the
imagination but
i can see the inevitable coming and and
i'm i'm not going to
allow that to happen without trying to
make a difference
so
that the most people have the wrong
impression of who you are
okay well first we have a bad audio
situation so you're echoing
you're echoing a lot so we should fix
that because
we won't converse well if
i'll go ahead and answer the last
question while we're waiting
um i feel i believe that i'm
misunderstood by the people who want to
misunderstand me
um i think that
by and large that people have a good
idea of who i am um
and by and large that that
images positive in fact it's positive to
the point where i find it very difficult
to believe
um i mean for example i just finished a
podcast with matthew mcconaughey on
sunday
and you the youtube comments there's
about a million people have watched it
already
and so that's something in and of itself
but the comments are unbelievably
positive
like they're they're heartbreakingly
and that and the like to dislike ratios
running about 99 to 1.
and that's that's a little better than
typical
but usually it's between 50 and 100
and 100 or 50 and 99 to 1.
and usually the youtube comments are
overwhelmingly positive and that's
certainly been the case well i've been
ill and well my wife was ill
and so um you know you might
quibble and say that people have an
impression of me that's too positive
but if i had to have a problem that
would be a good problem
i think that my reputation
suffers among those for whom it's
convenient to
assume things about me that aren't the
least bit true
like that i'm alt-right for example in
my proclivities either
overtly or curve or covertly or that my
followers are
can be easily categorized in that manner
first that i have followers second that
they can be categorized in that manner
and none of that's true that those
aren't my political leanings
i'm not temperamentally inclined to
to any extreme viewpoint and in fact
find them
abhorrent i spent my whole life studying
extreme political views
um since i was 18 essentially
and my listeners and viewers and readers
are on youtube they're primarily male
but
my book 12 rules for life sold about
between 4.5 and 5
million copies now and it's not young
angry men who are
buying that and and it all you have to
do is
scroll through the youtube comments on a
popular video and you can see that and
almost none of the discussion is
political and
uh when i did my tour for the book it
wasn't a political tour it was
i'm a psychologist and i'm happy about
that
i'm comfortable with that and when i had
to make a choice in my life between
being political overtly and staying
working as a psychologist i've always
chosen the latter
so that's helped me that's why
yes yeah yeah yeah if i speak out a bit
now abcd
is it all working it's better yeah yeah
thank god for that
thank you sorry about that oh that's
okay you know there's bound to be the
odd tech glitch
i guess that's true i guess so um
i'm curious as you're describing that
huge public response to you
it's a very shocking and strange thing
to become a famous person particularly
yes
the famous person well actually i'm not
i'm not
certain that it's the controversy that's
been the most um
emotionally demanding i think it's
yeah well i i think i i've had this
incredible view into the
suffering of thousands and thousands and
thousands of people you know when i
i can't go out without people coming up
to me
michaela can attest to this but every
time i go out
wherever i go people stop me and
you know they have an instant deep
conversation with me
and they tell me that you know they're
they tell me about
well first of all they're usually
somewhat shocked and then they're very
polite
and then they tell me that they've been
watching my youtube videos or
listening to the podcast or reading my
book and that it's really helped them
in some manner and then they tell me a
little bit about that and they're
usually
quite emotional and um
it's uh
you don't have conversations like that
that often outside of the clinical
sphere and you certainly don't have them
repeatedly with strangers on the street
anybody to sub there's something about
it that's that's really
remarkably positive you know um
when i walk around on any city in some
sense it's like i'm at home
because where people know me because
people say
on the street they say well really nice
to see you out i'm
glad that your health is recovering it's
like being surrounded by
well by well-wishers and by friends and
i'm happy about it because
you know it's it's a great thing if
you're a clinical psychologist
to be able to extend your reach like
that
but part of what's overwhelming to me is
how it's direct evidence for how little
encouragement so many people get
they're starving
sorry i haven't done an interview for a
long time
of course
[Music]
he's okay but he hasn't done an
interview in a long time
trying to determine to
towel so that should do me through the
interview
do you um this enormous sense of
pressure of their expectations on you to
be able to
encourage them or guide them does that
feel like a big pressure
well it feels like a big responsibility
and but i i can't
it's an overwhelming responsibility and
it's very surprising
like it's hard to it's hard to believe
it's surreal it's always surreal and
it's so
universal i mean i was in serbia
from for months not so long ago and
it's the same there it's the same
everywhere i've gone
if it's an airport or a cafe or it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
everywhere in the world
i mean i think i've looked at my view
youtube views and
i think my youtube videos including the
interviews
have been viewed at least 600 million
times
and so it's a scale of exposure that's
well i mean it's not unparalleled
because there are no shortage of famous
people but
it's unparalleled it's certainly
unparalleled for me um
but it's there's also this international
element
to it that's also new you know youtube
is a universal
media platform and it's so powerful that
it's
unbelievable and if you
put yourself in its clutches then
well most of the time nothing will
happen but sometimes
there's a tremendous explosion i mean
it's not surprising to me in some ways
you know i knew when i was working on my
first book maps of meaning that i was
dealing with things that were
fundamental
a lot or i knew i mean i knew insofar as
my sense of knowing is reliable but
generally it's been reliable i i can
tell when i'm on to something
and i knew i was dealing with things
that were fundamental
and i watched the effect of my lectures
when i was a university professor
on my students and most of the students
who i taught
said the most common response to my
classes was that
it changed their life it changed the way
they looked at everything and
that was my experience having
[Music]
learned and thought through the
what i learned and thought through when
i wrote maps of meaning it changed the
way i looked at everything
so i mean i and i could see this coming
because
as my reach expanded electronically
that sort of response continued to occur
but youtube magnified that in a
way that's well it it's a lot to
adapt to you know i mean when all this
hit me i was already
55 or there or something you know and
i'd labored under relative obscurity
that that's been made more of than is
really the case
because my classes were always popular
and so i had a certain renown at the
university as a teacher and
i'd done some tv work for about 10 years
really before i made
the first couple of videos that went
viral
but i'd also set up the youtube channel
a couple of years before that and it was
accruing views not at an
exponentially growing rate but you know
there are still tens of thousands of
people watching and that's not trivial
so but the response you asked me about
responsibility
i i i've certainly felt that when i
would have been
ill over the last year
i mean i thought it was one of the
things that really kept me alive
and i suppose it shaped my next book
because
i tried only to the the illnesses
and the responsibility i tried only to
keep
words that i found sustaining during
that period of time but
part of the reason that i stayed alive
was because i felt uh
overwhelming responsibility to
all the people who had been you know
affected by my work
i thought well that wouldn't go very
well if i just expired
somewhat melodramatically in the middle
of russia and middle of serbia
and so it was responsibility but also
tremendous support
you know it's quite something to be in
despair
and to have
thousands of people wishing you
well
and that's been my experience overall is
that
the the proportion of people who have
been supportive
to me and my family compared to the
proportion of people who've been
antagonistic there's no comparison the
tag it's not like the antagonism is
trivial and i don't
i it hits me i think it hits everyone in
the family i mean michaela's taken a lot
of flack
for squirreling me away in russia and in
serbia and you know profiting from my
corpse
so to speak and that's been hard on her
because like the rest of my family
well she put a lot on the line to help
me and that is the case for
many members of my family but you know
she she was
certainly the primary
mover of all this from the public
perspective and took a lot of flock for
it and that's been hard on her
but so the negative is
salient but the positive is overwhelming
and that was certainly
that was certainly the case on the tour
which was
a delight in many ways because it was so
unbelievably positive for
thousands of people who were gathering
together on a regular basis
different people in all these different
cities who were there fundamentally
because they wanted to get their lives
together
you know and the way that that was
treated by the people that were
antagonistic to me was
was exactly what you'd predict in if you
if you gave some credence to their
cynicism you know that it was a
political ploy or that i was exploiting
people or
they had no and that would be mostly the
radical
identity politics types who you know
who have no love lost for me and and
vice versa
it wasn't in their world view that
people could gather together like that
because they wanted to
improve but that that was the case
of 2018 um by that
point obviously your life has become
unrecognizably huge and you're going on
the book talk
to what except was your mental health an
issue for you during that year i think
you said to joe rogan that one of the
worst days of your life was days like
sam harris
not obviously oh yeah jesus god that
first discussion i had with sam harris
oh man i was just
um well i don't think it's a mental
health issue
i think it's a physical health issue i
have an autoimmune disorder of some sort
and it
has multiple symptoms one of the
symptoms is depression
and you know it's not really a classic
depression because
i don't i don't have the classic
cognitive symptoms i've never felt that
my life wasn't worth living i felt that
i was in so much
pain that i didn't know if i could
continue to exist
or that can you elaborate on that word
of pain because they come in so many
different things
well it would depend on on the
particulars of the circumstances i
suppose but
depression is a pain like phenomenon
it if you're depressed much of the
cortical circuitry that mediates
a pain response like a physical pain
response is activated
many people with depression have pain
syndromes like lower back pain is very
common among people who are depressed so
it is a pain
symptom it is a pain syndrome um
i guess the it's the the depression i
experienced
which is
characteristic of many people in my
family was
grief like i would say it felt like
overwhelming grief
and it was worse in the morning and and
uh would recede during the day but
it seemed to be part of a cluster of
symptoms that were
autoimmune in nature and much depression
is autoimmune in nature
so i don't really i think of it as i
think it's a physical illness
as far as i can tell when when i talk to
sam harris
um it's very complicated and i'm
i'm still trying to piece all of this
together but i had gone to see my family
my extended family on my
on my wife's side and michaela and
her husband and me both all of us came
down with the same
symptom set that lasted about three
weeks and it was absolutely terrible
um i i couldn't get up without
fainting i'd faint fall to the floor
gray out not blackout completely but
gray out
every time i got up i couldn't get warm
i was wearing multiple layers of clothes
and multiple layers of blankets and i
couldn't get warm
i had an overwhelming sense of of
doom and anxiety and
i didn't want to move and plus i
couldn't sleep for for days and days i i
don't i i was without sleep for many
weeks
and you know people have inadvertently
i have look that's what that's this is
it wasn't
no hold on there were no doubt it wasn't
apple cider it was sodium metabisulfite
in apple cider um like the alcoholic
apple cider was added to a stew
it was sodium metabisulfite in that
apple cider but it wasn't apple cider
right anyways in the midst of that
um which was
in the midst of that i talked to sam
harris and i was operating at about
five percent of my normal capacity if
that was terrible
but you know i wasn't going to forgo the
opportunity because
it was a necessary discussion now i was
nowhere near it i wasn't
i wasn't at my sharpest and you can
certainly tell that in the interview uh
you know i i couldn't respond rapidly
my my normal quickness of wit to what
degree i possessed that was certainly
absent in that first discussion with sam
but
it turned out that that was it worked
out all right because we had another
discussion and overall and
you know then i had these public debates
with sam too
that really i think we had 10 000 people
at the orpheum in london it would
it turned into something that neither of
us would have possibly imagined i don't
know if there's ever
i don't know if there's ever been a
larger public debate that's
certainly not on that kind of issue you
know and and who would have known that
that would become something that was so
popular that it was
what was somewhat of a cultural event
so i i don't think it's unreasonable to
to claim that
and so you would prescribe the
benzodiazepines as a result of that
incident
yes and a sleeping pill
by the family doctor were you talking
worried
did you did sort of alarm bells worrying
about women in the 50s and 60s you got
hooked on valium and couldn't get off it
and
well look when when benzodiazepines were
were first introduced they were touted
as
an almost completely safe replacement
for barbiturates
so i really didn't give it a second
thought what happened was well partly i
was
i was you know my life was an absolute
whirlwind at that
at that time um so it it fell if
if it had been an item of concern it
fell you know to number 20 on a list of
20 and
only 10 1 through 10 ever got attended
to
um you know at the time that i had this
terrible reaction other things were
happening the
the canadian equivalent of the irs was
after me
and and making my life miserable for
something they admitted
was a mistake three months later but
they were just torturing me to death
the college of psychologists that i
belonged to was after me because one of
my clients had put forth a
whole sequence of specious allegations
because the person was upset
that i had sort of disappeared over the
christmas vacation
so that was extraordinarily stressful
it wasn't clear to me whether my job was
going to continue
so you know there were other there were
other issues
plus i was at the epicenter of this
incredible controversy and there were
journalists
around me constantly and students
demonstrating and like it was a very
hectic time
in any case i took the benzodiazepines i
didn't take the sleeping pills i think i
took them two or three times and just
stopped but the benzodiazepines allowed
me to sleep again
and it was a very stressful time and uh
i just they were prescribed for two a
day and i just took them
and it wasn't like i was i couldn't feel
them they weren't
they i wasn't taking a high enough dose
so that i could actually detect the
effects of the
of the sedation they weren't sedating me
at all
they just stopped whatever had happened
to me which i still don't really
understand you know
we have a hypothesis that it was a
reaction to
allergic reaction to to the chemical
that michaela described but
but it was strange that all that the
three of us were affected by it and no
one else as well
anyhow well in any case that's what
david that's what the psychiatrist said
is that when you go off of ssris you can
be neurologically sensitive to chemicals
well that's the reasonable head lines up
yeah and i was probably
theory like we didn't turn up to a
doctor yeah that doesn't give it enough
credit like
there are doctors involved here no it's
not like we were no way yes and many of
them it's not like we've been sitting
around armchair hypothesizing about what
happened we've consulted many people to
try to figure this out
um and you heard by that point come off
ssris because of the diet is that right
because the efficacy of the diet
yes and the diet did a lot of different
things
had a lot of different effects on me uh
one of the most
market effects immediately was that i
stopped snoring and that that happened
within a week and was very
very surprising to me and then i i had
psoriasis and that cleared up and um
i had gum disease and that's that
cleared up which is
that's not curable gum disease so it's
treatable but not curable but it's
completely cleared up
and uh i lost 70 pounds over about a
seven month period
so it was the transformation was
remarkable and i've had other autoimmune
uh symptoms in my life i had alopecia
areata at one point and thought i was
going to lose all my hair but luckily
that
that stopped and i had this condition
called peripheral uveitis which is an
inflammation in the
in the tissue of the eye and markers on
my fingernails for
autoimmune like in an autoimmune
condition your body attacks its own
cells and i had markers for that as well
so there's an and i have had a
lengthy history of mouth ulcers um
but there's never been a formal
diagnosis of the nature of the
autoimmune disorder
immune disorder yes twice in the last
year okay
um right in russia and in serbia because
they did blood tests
dad yep i'm back it's just in russia
it they never pinpointed what it was in
russia it was fibromyalgia
and in serbia they thought fibromyalgia
but it was from
blood markers and so they were going
based on blood markers and symptoms and
put fibromyalgia on it yeah i mean these
autoimmune conditions aren't very well
understood and
and fibromyalgia is a good example of
that it's
it's terror incognita um so the
benzodiazepine seemed to help sort of
resolve that issue but you talked about
how
i've read you talking about how you felt
that it kind of muted somewhat your
relation
your relationships with people well it
was very confusing
it was very confusing time you know
because
a lot of what was happening to me was
also
in some sense alienating me from
from myself and my family because it was
so different
from what had happened before so trying
to
discriminate between the strange and
surreal conditions of my life and
the effect of this drug i never thought
about the drug having any effect on me
with regards to this muting and for
quite a long time and then
and while i also started to get kind of
weak on my left side and i
kind of thought at that point that the
benzodiazepine might have had something
to do with it
but i wasn't sure and that thought would
you just come up now and then and i
complained about it
that i had a weak weakness in my in my
musculature on the left side
but i never thought much of it and i
wasn't that worried i wasn't thinking
about the benzodiazepines like 10 hours
a day or anything like that
i never thought about it at all i was
extraordinarily busy
16 hours a day flat out seven days a
week for
for well right until tammy went into the
hospital in i
don't know right until michaela went
into the hospital in january of
2019 it was
flat out running and so i wasn't sitting
around thinking about
what was happening with me and you know
if i was a bit off well so was my life
it wasn't exactly
uh surprising that all of this might
have had some effect on my
relationships and that was kind of that
was subtle anyways i
mean we talked about it you know the
kids would tell me that
i was distant but
that's not a five alarm fire bell being
somewhat distant especially under
under strange circumstances
um including visiting 160 cities in 200
days
jesus and i was functioning obviously i
mean i gave a different lecture every
night
were you enjoying yourself yeah it was
amazing
yeah it was amazing and i don't think
enjoying myself doesn't really
cover it it's it was it was the best
year of your life
dreamlike um i wouldn't necessarily say
that i've had some pretty good years
it was the it was it was surreal
but it was it was surreal in a way that
was also
see one of the markers for
post-traumatic
post-traumatic stress disorder is
derealization right when
the things around you don't seem real
and
i was in a constant state of
derealization from october 2016
october 2016 until january 12th of 2021
go on explain well
i i didn't i still don't really have the
i
i'll give you an example so one day
this would have been in 2017 probably
and so things haven't got as busy as
they were going to get
[Music]
200 of my colleagues signed a
petition at the university of toronto to
have me removed from my
tenured position and my faculty
association
so an association to which i belong
forwarded that to the administration
without even notifying me
and my son came over to talk to me and i
said julian
um you know 200 of my colleagues just
signed a petition
asking for my removal from the
university of toronto faculty and he
said
oh dad don't worry about that it's only
200 people
and we had got to the point by that time
where that sort of event was
well produced exactly the kind of
response he had like
under normal circumstances i believe for
anyone
who's employed by an organization the
news that
200 of their colleagues had conspired
um inappropriately to
bring about their demise would be enough
to rattle them for
to rattle them into silence permanently
instantly
and for us that was barely noticeable as
a blip
on on the horizon given everything else
that was going on
and as it turned out it had absolutely
no effect
maybe a somewhat negative effect
in terms of the reputation of the
university but no effect on me
so practical effect but do you think it
had a kind of residual effect you're
talking about derealization and ptsd
that these kinds of
all of this has i still really don't
have a
proper conceptual framework in which to
slot all this
yeah um it's it's not it's not an easy
thing to understand
i don't know what to make of it what do
i what should i make of the fact that i
have 600
million views on youtube i don't know
what do you make of that
i mean on the one hand like i said i
knew that i was dealing with things that
were fundamental when i was writing maps
of meaning and
i watched the effect of what i had
learned on my students
and so that didn't and that grew across
time it continued to grow in a linear
fashion
and so and it in some sense that's not
that surprising because
all the ideas in in maps of meaning
which is really where i've derived
most of the ideas or many of the ideas
for my book 12 rules and for the new one
um you know i i studied
people who whose work i thought was
profound
and was able to integrate that and
to disseminate it and so the fact that
profound thoughts had effects on people
isn't that surprising and i'm not saying
that they were my thoughts because
maps of meaning has a very lengthy
bibliography and and
i use ideas that
towering intellects have generated
many of them psychologists and so the
fact that they had a powerful
psychological effect
makes sense it's it's still something to
be the messenger even if
you're not necessarily the originator
but
so that part wasn't what wasn't a
surprise in some ways but the magnitude
of the
the magnitude of the response has been
and the nature of the response the
emotional nature of the response has
been
continually amazing
you know when i was visiting tammy in
the hospital
well and then you know
not only did all did all of these things
occur
on the social front you got to think
about it this way you know i've watched
people respond to being
attacked on twitter
so they'll post something or write a
paper and 20 people will go after them
on twitter and that will produce a bit
of a storm
and they usually apologize profusely and
back the hell off and disappear
it's really really emotionally hard on
people to be attacked publicly like that
and that happened to me continually for
like three years and on a way larger
scale than 20 people
you know i mean the the even just the
events at
um um wilford laurier university with
lindsay shepherd
like was that was the biggest scandal
that hit a canadian university
certainly in my lifetime and that was
just that was a sideshow and i'm not
making light of it it wasn't a trivial
occurrence but it was just one of
dozens of things that were happening on
a regular basis the
demonstration at queen's university
when i when i went there to talk with
bruce pardy a lawyer
there i mean you know we were we were in
a building with
200 250 students 300 students i don't
know and
the protesters were outside at the
windows banging on the windows breaking
them in one case
it was completely surreal it was like a
zombie attack
um were you frightened by any of this
was any of it frightening
i guess i'd have yes i would say
definitely i mean yeah
i i would the most the fright i was
never concerned for my
i wasn't concerned for my life i wasn't
concerned for my physical safety
i was concerned for my family i was
concerned for my reputation
i was concerned for for my
my my occupation both as a clinical
psychologist because
i was under attack at the college of
psychologists as well as at the
university
um so and then there were times where i
was physically
threatened certainly that happened at
queen's university they arrested a woman
who was carrying a garat
for god's sake you know and and
um i i was harassed directly after the
demonstration there by us you know a
small coterie of
of insane protesters um
let's say committed protesters who were
in my face for two blocks three blocks
yelling and screaming with
my son was with me and you know the
university security guards they didn't
know what to do they weren't trained for
that sort of thing and i was very i was
i wouldn't say i was so much afraid
there was very angry like i
took everything i could not to knock the
man who was in my face flat
but i wasn't going to do that and uh
[Music]
and watchful i mean one of the
advantages i have had is that i am a
clinical psychologist you know and i can
detach myself from what's happening and
watch it
and that's partly when i'm being
interviewed by someone who's hostile and
and able to keep my cool it's partly
because i can watch
and also partly because i i know that
what's happening right now isn't the
whole story
you know it's especially true in the
modern world with an interview it's like
the interview can be very hostile and
that by no means means that i'm under
attack
it just feels like that in the moment
like with with the interview with
with kathy newman for example on channel
4 or there was another interview
done by a a woman who works for gq
which i think yeah it's been viewed 22
million times i believe at the moment
so it's just it's just under the kathy
newman video
in terms of number of viewers that was a
very
very uh
animus possessed interview she was on
my case right from the moment i walked
into the room essentially
and um presumably you knew that would be
the case i mean helen lewis is a very
established feminist
professional feminist well i didn't i
didn't know that it would be the case
at that time i was being i was being
interviewed so often that i never had
any time to prepare for the interview
i just walked into them and i assumed i
assumed at least that there would be
you know common professional courtesy
and most of the time that was the case
was certainly the case with kathy newman
who was
very professionally polite when we
first met in the green room and then
well and then
why didn't and then went on the attack i
suppose
um when she was interviewing me but both
of those interviews
the tide turned you know and it was very
very strange with the kathy newman
interview because first of all people
were rather sympathetic to me and then
she reported um being harassed
especially online and then so the
sympathy sort of
moved over to her side of the equation
let's say and then
for one reason or another it shifted
back to me um
[Music]
but do you think but did you enjoy them
in real time during those two hours with
helen nelly and
half an hour with kathy
no oh yes with kathy i enjoyed a second
of it
wait a second well when she stopped
when when i see there was one point
where she was reduced to silence
and i'd asked her a very serious
question which was how
why she thought it was okay to go after
me for
making people uncomfortable with my
opinions when it was okay
for her to go after me and make me as
uncomfortable as possible
in this particular scenario and she had
no answer to that and she had no answer
to that because
she knew perfectly well that she was
being hypocritical
and she stumbled and stopped speaking
and i said
gotcha and i enjoyed that and i thought
like in that half a second i thought
long and hard about whether or not i was
going to say that
i knew it would be funny and i do have a
sense of humor although it's rather
suppressed
he's been rather suppressed over the
last couple of years
yeah and i took a calculated risk and
i would say that i enjoyed that because
the timing was
right and
but it was a risk man it could have
easily gone badly right
you certainly withstood all kinds of
pressures
and stresses and navigated an
extraordinary roller coaster and kind of
kept it all together and handled it
up until 2019 when your wife is in
hospital and
being given this devastating well
2019 was you know it was just it
started out rough yes i went to
switzerland and i was
and i was in switzerland with michaela
for
well for a number of weeks when she was
having her ankle
rebuilt by carpenters i mean it was very
dramatic surgery um and the outcome
wasn't
obvious she could have easily lost her
leg and lots of people that she talked
to who suggested that that would be the
case
and so and it was strange to set up camp
in zurich and
and to bring her food and and to take
care of her and then
we went to australia for a whirlwind
tour in february and that went quite
nicely and then
well things just things just fell apart
insanely with tammy you know it was just
every bloody day was a life and death
crisis for like five months
and initially we were informed that her
illness was highly treatable and
minor and you know just
in a typical cliched movie scene we went
to see the doctor
after she had had her surgery but wasn't
recovering quite properly and they said
well
she's contracted this cancer that's so
rare there's virtually no literature on
it and the one-year fatality rate was a
hundred percent
and that was just the beginning of
you know endless nights sleeping on the
floor in emergency
and continual surgical complications and
and
so and then and then you know
my mood was was wavering at that point
um
i was taking a bit more of the
benzodiazepine
under still being supervised by my
my gp but i started to react to it
in a paradoxical manner it seemed to be
making me more anxious rather than less
and
i tried various and uh my depression
seemed to be making a comeback so
i tried various means of dealing with
that but it just got worse and worse and
at one point i stopped taking the
benzodiazepine all together
and that what happened when you did that
i developed this condition called
akathesia which i didn't
yes and let me tell you um
you wouldn't wish that on it's
unbearable
to say the least and you know they say
with akathisia people are driven to
suicidality within an hour
of of the onset of the symptoms i had
academia for
800 hours 900 hours 1000 hours
sometimes seven hours a day unbelievable
what did it feel like
well imagine that so imagine i just
figured this out a way to communicate it
probably
to some degree properly in the last
couple of days so imagine that someone
jabbed you really
hard in the ribs with their fingers and
stiff fingers you know you'd kind of
you'd pull away and then there'd be a
spasm from that
and you'd move well then imagine that
that's happening 50 times and
every time you breathe that's
that's sort of what it's like that level
of physical pain and discomfort
yeah yeah and it doesn't go away it's
just there and it's there and it's there
and it's there and
every time you breathe it's there you
can't sit and you know
i couldn't sit down i've been able to
start sitting down
again in the last month so you and i
could not have had
a conversation like this where we're
just talking to each other
i might have been able to do it um it
would recede to some degree as the day
went on
it was way worse in the morning and
wouldn't get better in the evening
so it would have depended on the time of
day but certainly
even now you know i really don't get
going until two o'clock or so in the
afternoon
right i'm my my morning schedule is
still very very rigid
but it's it's it's uh it's
[Music]
yes it's on it's unbearable the
sensation
and it's also humiliating because it's a
voluntary movement disorder
and so what that means is that it feels
like you're doing it
and i could also control it so if it was
happening and i was
twisting and moving and walking around
in my bedroom
uncontrollably thousands and thousands
of times if
one of those people who were caring for
me a nurse or a doctor said well can you
stop it i could i could stop it
although i had a hard time stopping the
effect of the breathing
it's not voluntary one of the symptoms
of akathisa is that it feels
voluntary this is in agatha
so one of the torturous things about it
is it feels voluntary
there are other like psych side effects
well and you can contribute you can stop
it at least briefly well yeah there's a
disorder called dyskinesia
where you move but you don't you don't
even know you're moving it's
so it's it it's an uncontrollable
movement disorder but it's
involuntary it doesn't affect the
voluntary motor system
but academia does and so there's always
this sense that you could stop it if you
just exercised enough willpower
so it's humiliating as well and does
that also generate a kind of
self-punishing dynamic in your head that
you're angry with yourself
disgusted i would say more than angry
disgusted
when you feel as if you're being kind of
grotesque and ridiculous and weak
is it or yes definitely it's not only
that you feel like you're being that
it's it's that is the situation or
that's certainly how it appears
a grotesque for sure and did you feel
incredibly self-conscious about
it and being oh no after a while i just
like
being self-conscious it was so awful
that being self the problem of being
self-conscious fell way down the
the uh like if you're in enough pain
you're no longer self-conscious
it's there but it's i shouldn't say that
you're still self-conscious but
that problem is so it's trivial compared
to the pain
ah it was horrible i mean i'm that's the
other thing that's so strange about this
and and that's also made this surreal is
that i'm actually a very private person
prior to all this i never discussed my
own personal affairs with anyone i
never talk about my illness i don't talk
about how i'm doing
i have done that with depression to some
degree because i thought there was a
public service element in it
you know because our my family has
battled it for a very long time
and i felt that some public disclosure
of that
would perform a reasonable public health
uh
function but other than that i'm not
inclined
towards personal self-disclosure and
certainly not on a mass scale
so that's also been very strange to have
all of this
be so public over the last two years
and saying that you know brings up a
wave of disbelief that that can be the
case
that that's is actually is it a panicky
wave or is it just incredulity
[Music]
at now i think it's mostly just
incredulity
so you probably should try to get
treated twice in
north america first in the eastern
seaboard
at all do you even remember much about
those two
i don't remember anything about toronto
uh there's a i don't remember
from december 16th to february 5th i
don't of
of 2020 the end of 2019 the beginning of
2020. i don't remember anything at all
do you think you even did you know that
you were being that you were flying to
moscow to be pointless
yeah so in real time you were fully
aware of it but you've got no memory of
it now
that's right yeah i mean obviously what
lots of people would say is
well this is obviously i've talked to
various people about this and everyone
says
why on earth would a high profile north
american
i went to the best treatment clinic in
north america and connecticut
and all they did was make it worse
they were out of options like we were
out of options
my the the judgment of my family was
that i was likely going to die in
toronto
and so there was a giant toronto again i
mean lots of people
would say why would you sort of trust
the judgment although your family
members love you they're not trained
qualified medics
why would you why would you put yourself
in their hands and not the medical
professions
i had put myself in the hands of the
medical profession
and the consequence of that was that i
was going to die
and we put ourselves in the hands of
medical professionals in russia too
so it wasn't like we were fleeing
completely fleeing from the medical
profession
i tried a slow taper on the
benzodiazepines and i couldn't do it
yeah you know and i went to this the
treatment clinic in in on the eastern
seaboard and they had
promised essentially um a 12-week
treatment program and my impression of
that was that
at the end of that 12-week period i
would be free of benzodiazepines
but that isn't how it worked out at all
and i was
i was on more medication when i left
that treatment center than i was when i
went in
were you angry with them are you arguing
with them
no why not
there was no point in in being angry
that wouldn't be helpful
i was disappointed i mean when i when i
went when i went there to begin with uh
right at admission they basically told
me that
the 12-week program was unlikely to be
successful and i thought
oh this is a hell of a time to be
informing me of that since i've just
come down from toronto
but by that time i was well there wasn't
any alternatives
at that point so
you know i was in i was in a
sufficiently dire state so that
it wasn't tenable for me to maintain my
residence
the clinic to the clinic you went to in
moscow they were more they're more
familiar with doing a kind of induced
coma
to have some a speedy withdrawal from
opiates rather than
benzodiazepines is that right uh
michaela would probably be better
able to answer that than me yeah you're
back
i suppose again one of the things that
people absolutely associate you with
is that you are meticulous about
following the data you know it's almost
a kind of peterson catchphrase there's
no evidence for that you know you're
very much an
evidence based person what was the
evidence that you saw
that was so compelling and overwhelming
to take you to moscow
i couldn't do the the um i couldn't do
the
i couldn't tolerate the uh the gradual
taper
so it was the only other alternative
that's all wasn't that it was compelling
it was that we were out of options
right yeah the treatment i received in
on the eastern coast and in toronto
didn't help it made it worse
yeah so we didn't have any other options
what were you most frightened of at that
point i know michaela's talked about
your kind of guys
levels i was i was most afraid of
academia
like there isn't anything else that like
every day i had academia was the worst
day of my life
by a huge margin not by some trivial
amount but by a huge margin
it was absolutely unbearable i i mean i
tried to describe it
yeah i did
it's very difficult to describe it's
like pain
but it's a pain that that you can't
that only movement will satisfy i mean
even now i'm walking 10 miles a day
yes yes i heard yeah so
i mean obviously the obvious thing that
critics your enemies would say i'm sure
you yeah
this is hardly going to be news to you
would be hold on a minute you know
you've
your entire intellectual framework your
philosophy of life is that life is about
suffering
about pain and that the manly strong
dignified thing to do is to accept that
pain and suffering and battle through it
and learn from it
and that the coward's way out is to try
and take drugs
to to um to no i've never said that
i've never said that and as a clinician
i mean
um i've had many people in my
practice look if you're if you're a
viable clinician
you encourage people to take psychiatric
medication when it's appropriate
and many people in my practice were
helped to a tremendous degree by
antidepressants i was
they were they were unbelievably helpful
to me and to my and to other members of
my family
not universally and not without a cost
but
but very very helpful and you know
that's a curricular viewpoint too
what what i really encourage people to
what i what i encourage in people is the
um
[Music]
it isn't useful to allow your suffering
to make you resentful
even though you have many you have
reason for that and so
part of the battle it's a ridiculous
caricature that
that perspective you know life people
people are hurt badly by their lives in
all sorts of ways and
becoming bitter and resentful about that
means that you start to
cause extra suffering in yourself and in
your family members and in your
community and that's not helpful
it's not helpful and believe me i mean
i've i've had plenty of
temptation to become resentful about
what's happened
to me in the last two years with my
wife's terrible illness and
well with my daughter's illness first of
all and then with my wife's illness and
then with mine
you know and and i've certainly had my
moments where i thought
it was torturous because it was
unbelievably torturous because i was in
agony and and with with an indeterminate
uh prognosis but certainly one
that indicated that this would last for
months and months and only slowly recede
months and months and perhaps years um
i was shut off from my family
except for well for much of this time
and among strangers who didn't speak my
language
and at the same time i was
i had this plethora of opportunities
sitting in front of me
none of which i was able to access like
i love my wife and my
[Music]
my kids and my grandkids and
it was it was it was like a a
nightmarish surrealist novel i had all
this waiting for me
all this life i put together so
carefully and it was
constantly dangled out of my reach that
was
completely consciously aware of that the
condition i
i developed made it impossible for me to
live at home
so i was divorced from
from my profession from all the things
that i was working on and from everybody
that i loved
i had plenty of reason to become like
many people do
to become bitter it's not helpful
[Music]
when i watched the podcast that you did
with michaela
i thought you looked angry at moments
and i was wondering who you
who or what you were angry with
well pain will make you angry right
you know so
faint i suppose it was
i mean i would say
well we've had our health troubles in
our family for the last few years
many years and the last two years were
surreal in that regard again
it was just too much
and so i was never
very rarely angry when i was in the
hospitals
never angry at the nurses or doctors or
very rarely
[Music]
is there anybody that's angry with
yourself for taking benzodiazepines
when now that you know how dangerous
they are
angry
i wouldn't say angry um
i i it's not like i failed to see the
irony
that was another thing about this that
made it quite
still continues to make it difficult to
stomach
you know i could should have i known
better
possibly well i mean i did do my thesis
on alcoholism
although you know this isn't hold up
yeah you had a side effect from a
medication
should you have known better that
benzodiazepines can cause academia in
people who take ssris
no you didn't have it like this it
turned this wasn't benzodiazepine
dependency
problem this was an akathesia side
effect from psych meds
yes and no i couldn't have known that
yes that's right um
i have to say we have ten minutes before
we have to wrap up yeah i'm doing okay
by the way
yeah yeah i know but still or mom will
kill me
[Music]
so deca what else do you want to talk
about i was curious about whether you as
a sort of art soviet critic where the
irony was also not lost on you that
about
ending up in russia to have your life
saved how do you make sense of that does
that just seem like one of the bizarre
coincidences
of life yes it's it's
no i don't know how to make sense of
that i don't know how to make sense of
the fact that tammy recovered the day of
our 30th wedding anniversary
which is literally the case the surgical
complications that were
threatening her life ended on that day
and she had told me a few months earlier
that she would recover on our 30th
wedding anniversary
it's like
[Music]
i don't know how to make sense out of
that
[Music]
it was it was
yeah i don't know what's what to what to
think about that there's lots of things
i don't know what to think about
this the diet too has been a complete
shock
so that's maintain been maintained
throughout this whole process the
hospitals were all willing to feed you
your diet is that right well i don't
know how willing they were but
but um that's what happened that's what
happened
[Music]
so i'm sure some people reading this
are going to say this is all kind of
pharmacological flim-flam
surely to god it's much less complicated
than all of this
why we have someone with a history of a
history of depression
who's lived through extraordinarily
stressful
surreal as you say few years managing
unimaginable pressures and demands and
pace of life
and this has got nothing to do with
medicine or farmer
pharmaceuticals this is purely just
about
somebody cracking under the pressure of
life
is that a possibility that you've
considered well there's no doubt that
asia is then that's right that well
that's the basic answer to that
is that like i didn't develop akathesia
until i stopped taking
tried to stop taking the benzodiazepines
so
now whether the i don't know
i can't say what additional effect the
pressure had on making me more
susceptible to akathisia for example i
i don't think anybody could answer that
and i certainly know that
stress makes it worse but stress
makes everything worse so that's not
that helpful
um what's causing you the greatest
stress now
fear that the academia will come back
i mean i i've had it five days well in
the last 43 days i've had
in november i had 26 academic days out
of 31
right and those would last those
episodes would last anywhere from five
to seven hours
so that was just horrific
in december i had five days i was a
catholic
and in january so far none although it's
still
lurking there i can feel the impulse
yeah but i can keep it under control
or it's or it's not intense enough
to overwhelm me i don't want to claim
um i don't want to make any unwarranted
moral claims about the effect of my will
it certainly
seems that i am effortlessly suppressing
the desire to move
constantly almost constantly but that's
starting to recede and the mornings are
still very
very very difficult but is it difficult
you mean difficult to get started
difficult to kind of get your brain into
gear well i get up
and and i start breakfast and then i go
and i have a sauna for an hour and a
half and then i
i'm in the shower and i scrub myself for
about 20 minutes and i usually can
hardly stand up at that point
and then i eat and by the time i start
to eat then i'm i'm starting to
be i can walk with
at a somewhat normal pace by then and
then i usually walk for anywhere between
two and four hours
and and then i can have i'm beginning to
have uh something resembling a
productive day
my cognition is sharp enough now again
so that i can
well engage in an interview like this
for example or i've been
increasingly um
participating in podcasts and that's
probably that's been the other thing
that's so difficult is my life was so
bloody complicated that
when it when i stopped my
occupational activities it was very very
difficult to start them up again because
it's like jumping into a car that's
going 900 miles an hour
you know i did a podcast with matthew
mcconaughey on
december 22nd i think and it was
released yesterday and
something on the order of a million
people 1.2 million people i think have
watched it by now it's
i'm to jump back into my life is to jump
back
into that there's no simple entry point
and so that's been a real problem
i i i i haven't known what to do
the other thing that happened to me that
was
terrible in in 2020 is that i had this
terrible
uh experience of time dilation
so when i first woke up in russia i was
asking michaela when she'd come and
visit me i'd ask her what time it was
10 times in 10 minutes assuming that
something on the
order of half an hour or an hour had
gone by
since the last time i asked her and so i
had these torturous days that were like
a hundred times longer than they should
have been
so that's receded and now i my days are
there they last the proper amount of
time
yes thank god how are you feeling about
the prospect of the book coming out and
all the demands that that entails and
the opportunities that that entails
well i'm i'm ambivalent about it because
i'm ambivalent i'm ambivalent about it i
can't
judge the book properly i didn't write
it under optimal circumstances
to say the least and
so i'm unsure i can't tell i can't make
an adequate judgment of its quality
i know i believe that my capacity for
editing wasn't what it could be
yeah but that was offset to some degree
by the fact that i was able to
filter what i was writing through the
lens of my illness and
to eradicate everything that wasn't
sustaining for me while i was
in such trouble so it's amazing to me
that you were able to work on the book
during that
year you would if you would have seen me
believe me it would have been more
amazing when i recorded the book
the audiobook in in november
i was acaphesic almost the entire time
and so 26 days in november
well i would go to the studio virtually
convulsing in the car
like unable to control my movements
unable to control my arms unable to
control my legs
thrashing about and and tammy would
drive me there
or my son some and then the same thing
would happen in the lobby i
i was moving just frenetically and then
i'd go to get upstairs into the studio
and force myself to sit down and then
force myself to not move for two hours
and do the recording
because i i was if you would have asked
me to lay odds on the probability that
well that i would live to finish the
recording i would have bet you ten to
one that i wouldn't have but certainly
as well that i wouldn't have been able
to do the recording but
i did the recording so it's done and it
was the same with the book
i mean i have i've had lots of support
you know my family
has supported me tremendously and and
the professional staff
that i've had the fortune to employ have
helped me and
my viewers have supported me and all of
that's helped a lot
and so but you know
i can tell you why i did it how i could
do it
it was easy the alternative was worse
you know if i would have lost the book
i wouldn't have had anything left no job
no no function you know what i'm a
i like to work and i've always tried to
be
it's like a game in some sense i've
always tried to be as productive as
possible on as many fronts
as possible simultaneously and i've
practiced that
since i was in graduate school
and it's a game at constant challenge
and
you know i first lost contact with my
professional life
well probably when i went on the tour
but the tour of course
filled in that gap but then when i i
spent all my time in 2019
in the hospital with tammy and that
disrupted my professional life
completely and then
i got so sick i couldn't get it going
again and so that was
two years but
but i had the book and so i'd
you know i'd get to the point where
i could sit a bit at by three o'clock
and i'd think okay i'm going to sit and
write and it was
it was hellish but the the thought that
i'd stop
and and that would fold up and i'd have
nothing that was worse and so
you know if you're caught between the
devil and the deep blue sea at least you
have
your choice of demise and so i
it was better to work than to not work
and that that's definitely the case
so that's why to my degree that i can
explain
how i was able to manage it i'm not
going to talk about willpower courage
i'm going to talk about the lesser of
two evils
yeah that makes sense um we've only got
a second uh yeah
let me ask you one question then i just
wanted to ask you a little bit about
recent news events
um if you can tell about the clock five
years what would you do differently
i wouldn't take benzodiazepines are you
angry with the doctor who prescribed
them to you who knew that you were
already done to 15 years on ssris no
look um he he he served
he was my my daughter's physician as
well and he was very helpful to us
for a large part of her trouble and so
it would have no i'm not angry with him
maybe he should have known better but
maybe i should have known better too
and like you know he he also it wasn't
like i was consulting him every month
there was no reason there was no reason
to to raise red flags i was on a
relatively moderate dose of
benzodiazepine and that's it's not like
that's rare
it's unbelievably common now it's not
good as it turns out the fda
put out warnings last fall you know
stating
quite clearly that these drugs shouldn't
be used for more than 10 days but the
fda didn't
drive that message home until last fall
so those are the breaks you know
and and i'm not happy and
i don't see how he could have no i don't
harbor any resentment towards him
and just before we finish can i just ask
you a quick question
about recent news events i'm sure
already
you've been as kind of gripped as the
rest of us by events in washington in
the last couple of weeks
um do you obviously lots of people are
now
saying actually i've revised my opinion
about trump i didn't think he was
dangerous i didn't think he was
and you had certainly said quite
commonly if you've called him a liberal
and a moderate no more of a democrat
demigods and reagan
um do you still feel that or have you
similarly changed your view about him
well i'm not i'm not really when i'm
looking at what's happening in the
united states in the last week i'm not
really thinking about it in terms of
trump
i'm thinking about it in terms of a
positive feedback loop that's developed
between the radical left and the radical
right and
that it's something that i saw coming
five years ago
and you can put it out at trump's feet
but it's not helpful i mean obviously he
was the immediate catalyst for the
horrible events that enveloped
washington the inexcusable events that
enveloped washington
and perhaps it'll all die down when
trump disappears but i doubt it
and what i see what's happening is
there's a feud
going on and the feud is between the
radicals on both sides of the political
distribution
and the left will do something extreme
and the right reacts and the right will
do something
extreme and the left reacts and the left
blames the right and the right blames
the left and that's a feud and they're
both right
they can both point to incalculably
stupid things that they're they're
opposites across the political spectrum
have engaged in
the danger is that we won't be able to
dampen this down
now if biden is wise and i'm hoping
that he is he'll
dampen the positive feedback loop down a
system is in a positive feedback loop
when
it amplifies its own behavior
and that's what's happening and that can
easily get out of control
and biden now has sufficient political
power so that he could
emerge on the world stage as a genuinely
moderate democrat
he could leave the identity politics
behind
and rule in a clinton-esque fashion
and that would be good and we'll see i'm
i'm hoping he can manage that but
the the american political situation is
it's a robust country and it's been
through worse
but there's always the danger that
things can
spiral out of hand are you more worried
now than you were five years ago
four years ago no i'm not actually i
think that
all things considered
2020 could have been a hell of a lot
worse politically given the fact that
there is a simultaneous pandemic
people are under an awful lot of stress
everyone
they're too isolated they're they're cut
off from their family members they're
under unbelievable economic strain
and they're also susceptible to the
paranoia-inducing influence of the
bubbles that
have emerged on social media and then
those are
that that technology is exacerbating
people's
conspiratorial mindsets because they can
find like-minded people and don't
encounter correction
it's not good but having said all that
we're not doing too badly you know if
we're lucky the vaccinations will
precede a pace we'll start to see a real
decrease in the intensity of the
epidemic by the end of march or the
beginning of april it's not that far
away
it'll be mostly the vaccinations will be
universally accessible by september
and biden will have proved to be
intelligently
moderate and cautious and will squeak
through this
now
that's that's the most likely outcome as
far as i'm concerned and it's certainly
the one that i'm hoping for
so you know my my my objections to the
identity politics types were
elicited in large part because i thought
that
the continual pushing on the radical
leftist front
would wake up the sleeping right
and so it came to pass well we'll see
you know i'm not going to say that that
was accurate
i don't know how awake the sleeping
right is you know and
what happened in washington was
appalling
but it was also stupidly appalling thank
god
you know there was an element of
farcical theater about it
and and so that's a relief in some sense
like it's much better to see stupidity
than malevolence than organized
malevolence and
i'm not saying there was no organized
malevolence there certainly was
but there was plenty of theatrical
stupidity and trump is definitely
egging that on you know and and he's
divisive in that
very divisive manner
i think he should be ignored
that the best thing that could happen is
that he would fade away
an impeachment will amplify
well i'm not claiming to be omniscient
in these matters
but yes i think that impeachment will
just ma it's
god he's gone what hang on a sec
[Music]
he's gone in a week and the democrats
could busy themselves with
getting the goddamn vaccinations out
you know biden spiden could be a
successful president instantly if he did
nothing else but
vaccinate 100 million people in the next
three months and there isn't anything
that's anywhere near as important as
that and i'm hoping that what happened
with trump
and his his incitation his inciting to
to to um protest i'm hoping that'll fade
away and that
wise people will allow it to do exactly
that i don't think stoking the flames is
a good idea i've never thought that
that's what i can
from my perspective i could see what was
coming
too much too much ideological nonsense
too much
identity politics that's why trump was
elected to begin with
the democrats alienated their their
working-class voter base
they sacrificed their typical the people
that they had stood for for
for decades on the altar of identity
politics and i know why that is too the
democrats don't have any policy-making
procedure
it's not part of the political a part of
the political system and so what that
means is the
the radicals who have a narrative
control the rudder
because they have a narrative and the
centrists don't
and this is absolutely clear i've been
to washington many times now and watched
it
so the centrists need a story and there
is a story the story would be
peace and prosperity for all of us
low-cost energy
you know an economic an economic program
that would that would that would benefit
everyone but maybe even most
particularly the poor because inequality
is a real problem
inequality destabilizes societies it's
clear
and so if you're a right-winger or a
left-winger you have your reasons to
control inequality
if you're a right-winger you control
inequality because you don't want your
society to spiral out of control
and if you're a left-winger you control
inequality because it's unfair that the
people at the bottom are suffering the
way they are the ones that stack up at
zero
it's a it's an unbelievably deep problem
and
cheap ideological solutions aren't going
to solve it you know
inequality isn't a function of
capitalism
it's it's not there's no evidence for
that whatsoever
and so the the continually attempts of
the radical leftists to blame inequality
on capitalism are
self-defeating and and if if
if you were i was talking to um matt
ridley the other day he wrote the
rational optimist a number of other
books you know and
one of the things you might derive from
matt's books is that if you were
truly concerned with the poor and with
the environment you would do everything
you could to make the poor as rich as
possible as fast as you possibly could
because rich people care about the
environment and
the fastest way to lift rich poor people
out of poverty is
through free market capitalism clearly
and the evidence for that is quite
pronounced since the soviet union
collapsed
more people have been lifted out of
poverty than in the entire course of
human history before that
from 2000 to 2010 ha
the number of people who were in
absolute poverty in the world fell by
half
the chinese just announced its
radication last week
and by 2030 the u.n predicts that there
will be no absolute poverty anywhere in
the world
so there are alternatives to this
terrible ideological idiocy that's
that's threatening the stability of of
that's threatening this
that's threatening stability in places
like the united states
anyways look i have faith in in western
democratic
institutions and the americans have been
through all sorts of upheavals in the
past and come through with flying colors
and i think the same thing will happen
now
i pray that biden keeps the radicals in
his party under control he has the
mandate to do that
he was a moderate he was elected as such
and there's plenty of moderates in the
democrat
in the democratic party that he could
rely on he doesn't have to pander to the
radicals and i've seen some evidence of
that pandering already it's very
unfortunate
you look at that exactly like we should
wrap this up
yeah otherwise i'm just going to wonder
why we've been doing this for an hour
and 40 minutes
okay okay okay i look exactly
that you would be eminently recognizable
to anyone who's ever followed you
already or
i suppose just before that i'm curious
do you think what
what in any if in any way do you think
the experience of the last year has
changed you
as a person
i have far more appreciation for
the banality of the normal
you have no idea what a privilege it is
to be able to sit down
on that note thank you
i have to shut it down so look before we
before we stop i think we should think
about this
deca you should think about whether you
got everything you wanted
i mean i want this interview to be
i want you to be satisfied with this
interview
and uh it's in it's obviously in my
interest
as well as yours that you're satisfied
with this interview and so
if you have other questions if you think
there are things that we haven't talked
about
if you think there are lacunae in in our
conversation
then let us know okay and we'll make
arrangements to talk to you again
fantastic thank you i really really
appreciate this all of you thank you
yeah
i guess i i have one other one question
for you too
[Music]
i think of all the things i think it
would be a mistake
to tilt this discussion too much towards
the details of my illness because the
story
the story here that hasn't been told
properly is
the reason for the tremendous hunger
that's manifested itself for the sorts
of things that i've been talking about
and there isn't a journalist who's got
that right yet
and i think that's because journalists
tend to look at things from a political
perspective and this hasn't been
a fundamentally political
what i've been doing hasn't been
fundamentally political even though it's
been cast that way
you know i've been trying to help people
i've been trying to point out to people
that they need a profound meaning in
their life because their lives are
difficult
and without a sustaining meaning then
you can become bitter and that's a bad
outcome
and also that the meaning that you need
to sustain yourself is to be found
through responsibility
and that's the fundamentally that's the
fundamental
message that's resounded with people
it's that
small equation meaning
justifies suffering and meaning is to be
found through responsibility
and no one no one is
no one is delivering that message
but it's it's it's not optional that
knowledge
it's vital people can't live without
knowing that
and so that's what i've been telling
people is that look your life is going
to be hard
and that can warp and and hurt you in a
way that
will incline you to make things worse
rather than better
but you can forestall that without being
naive
by taking on the proper responsibility
in your life
for yourself and for your family and for
your community and that's real
that makes things better it's not just
the psychological paper over
it's the genuine article and then i have
all these thousands of people who are
continually communicating with me
who say i've tried that i tried that i
was desperate and i tried that
and it works
so that shouldn't be lost in the shuffle
and
and in the details of my you know
bizarre affliction
it's a sideshow
in jamaica
okay thanks very much
okay
hello hi michaela how are you doing
good not bad how are you i'm okay we're
um
i'm not feeling quite at my most
professional mckayla we've got stranded
in jamaica
um there are definitely worse places to
be stranded
you are not wrong
but the wi-fi in the house we're
currently in is slightly ropey so i've
just had a slightly nervy 10 minutes but
hopefully we'll be okay
okay okay hopefully hopefully i don't
mind um
and michaela thank you so much this is
really helpful if i can get a
full briefing from you yeah i just
wanted to do um so i'll give you
the brief story i've recounted it a
whole bunch of times to
every time we get a new doctor so um
i'll give you the background and i
wanted to do it because
my dad is he's still not fully recovered
he's probably not going to be fully
recovered for another year to be honest
and he's still extremely prone to
anxiety and so any recounting of it
is it knocks him out for a couple days
so hopefully tomorrow can if i give you
all the like nitty gritty
nasty details then he can fill you in on
you know
how he feels and everything but he won't
have to go through all
all of what happened yeah got you okay
so do you um let me start from
i'm i'm going to let him tell his story
i'm just going to tell the medical stuff
that he doesn't want to get into
okay so in in 20
he he was taking uh ssris for
i think i believe 14 years it was a long
time
um and to treat fairly severe depression
that seems to run in our family
and that was going on
was that sort of part of your family
experience your father's depression
yeah my great-grandpa had it and he
ended up on the
you know very depressed living on the
couch for the last
you know 10 years of his life like very
very depressed it hit my grandpa in his
40s and then it hit my dad
he said it was there but it wasn't bad
until his late 20s
and so he didn't start taking because he
didn't want to take medication for it
but it was starting to affect his
lecturing he wasn't able to lecture he
was working at harvard and
it started to affect his lecturing so he
started taking ssri and it
and it helped quite a bit and then it
hit me
and it hit me when i was really little
like 12.
so it's this familial depression and in
um we went on a low carb diet
he got a lot healthier you can see from
the videos
in 2015 to 2016 he lost
he went from 218 to 160. he lost a whole
bunch of weight
he had gerd and gum disease that got
better he had psoriasis that got better
and his depression started to get better
so
he went off of the antidepressants
and it was things were okay
and then they weren't okay and he went
on um
he went on rogan and he got a lot of
negative media for this but he talked
about this
uh sodium metabisulfite responds
in apple cider where he had severe
insomnia
and it is actually something that
happened it happened to both of us
and we now know what you were both
affected by it yeah it was over
christmas and it hit him
it hit it was really awful but it hit
him harder
he was and that was at the end of 2016.
is that right so this was after he had
been off of ssris for about
a year this was um at the end of
2016. yeah yeah it was at the very end
of 2016.
so he had this response where he got
pale he couldn't stand up without
blacking out
he wasn't sleeping he had this impending
sense of doom
and he'd had similar reactions like this
throughout the previous year
but then it had been interspersed with
no depression and then these
weird depressive reactions
so we had we had this reaction and he
went
to the doctor after about a week of
being he was in really bad shape like
um and this was kind of
at the same time he was under a lot of
stress because the book was about to
come out i was just gonna say
exactly he was i mean 2016 had been a
big year for him in his career yeah so
not only
was there this health thing but there
was actual life stress going on
so there was some question at u of t
about whether or not he was going to
keep his job um
so that was incredibly stressful and
then just
even just having people come up in the
street even though that was
overwhelmingly positive
just going from not being known to being
known
was stressful but the main our entire
family agrees the main problem here was
this
weird health thing and we were going to
doctors and they didn't really know what
was going on
so he was we went he went to the family
doctor and the family doctor put him on
a really low dose of a benzodiazepine
and just is that the same family doctor
who'd been prescribing the ssris before
then
yeah so um he just took it
and it helped with his especially with
the insomnia
um and then he had we didn't really
think about it because he'd been taking
ssris for
you know 14 years and then he had this
year where we were trying to get the
depression under control and then
so he was on another you know psych med
and we're like okay
whatever um at that time we were not
aware of
the response some people can have to
that so he he stayed on that and he did
his world tour and things were okay
um were pretty good i would say
and then my mom so you weren't concerned
at that point well it felt as if the
sort of situation had been managed
yeah well we thought we didn't really
know what these
i knew because i have an autoimmune
condition on top of it
and i'd been having these reactions
these ridiculous food reactions
that was also kind of ridiculed and so
we had similar reactions and
i didn't actually end up taking any
medication because i was pregnant at the
time
so i was like i'm not doing anything i'm
just whatever this is maybe it'll go
away
um so we didn't think about it
and about a year so it was
20 i want to make sure i get the years
right um
2020 2019 in 2019
2018 at the end of 2018 my mom got
diagnosed with cancer
yes um yeah and it was one of
it was kidney cancer one of the better
cancers
um and things were kind of slow in
canada so she didn't end up getting the
surgery she needed
until march and then about a month after
the surgery
um they said oh this isn't the type of
cancer we thought it was this is
actually
uh collecting duct carcinoma and you
have eight months
and nothing helps like they said we can
do surgery but
there's no really no response to chemo
and it's this extremely rare cancer
and we did a whole bunch of research and
it was this extremely rare cancer that
is
extremely deadly and at that point my
dad's
obviously it was just horrible because
it was she's healthy
she had no symptoms and then suddenly
had this
and so the doctor put the benzodiazepine
up and dad started to get
super weird um does that work because i
think originally he said he was on
0.25 and then it jumped up to 4
milligrams is that right i think that's
why
i don't know if it started at .25 twice
a day or
point five twice a day
okay but it was low and it went up to
four
and it went up it didn't go up from that
to four it went up
slowly because it went up a bit and he
got way worse
so he started getting what we now know
is akathesia
what did that look like yeah how did
that manifest again arcatho is a
uh it manifested as extreme
anxiety um and suicidality
something that he had never had being
depressed
like he'd never had suicidal even
thoughts
um being depressed so this was nothing
that i'd ever seen or that my family had
ever seen
and we immediately thought something's
going on with
medication but my mom was also on the
verge of death
and so we're like he's absolutely head
over heels in love with her
who knows how hard he's taking it
but he it was still something was wrong
right so then the doctor put the
medication up a little bit more and then
this got worse
and and then my dad who was trying to be
stable because of how horrible this
situation was
um went this was this is when things got
really bad he went to a psychiatrist in
toronto
who said okay you have treatment
resistant depression
um try ketamine but in order to try
ketamine you need to get off of the
benzodiazepines
and then he scheduled an appointment for
ketamine
and i'm not happy with the psychiatrist
because
you can't stop taking benzodiazepines
okay and we didn't know that
we found out but we didn't know that so
after so he stopped taking them to get
to do this ketamine treatment and he'd
stopped
like when he stopped the antidepressants
he had some side effects but
he'd he'd kind of stopped before
some of the summer times he didn't take
them when he felt a little bit better so
i didn't think about this anyway about a
week after stopping and after
two ketamine treatments he was
in terrible shape like and i went over
so suicide if i'd met him during that
period what would i have noticed
how would he presented um extremely
agitated
and almost like somebody who was in pain
to me it looked like
pain and i
went over there and i thought and i like
looked at him and i was like oh my god i
can't even talk to this guy right he's
not even here what's going on
and we called one of our friends who's a
psychiatrist and that guy said
he's in benzodiazepine withdrawal he
can't do that
right so he went back on but he went to
because at this point he was like oh no
i have this dependency
that i've formed i need to get off of
this stuff
um so we went back on to half the dose
um
and then it turned out he was just in
withdrawal because you have to
it's crazy some people have to titrate
down
by using drops of this medication which
isn't something
a lot of doctors know so when you're put
on the medication you're not gonna say
by the way to get off of this you might
need to cut your pill into slivers
right so anyway so then he was put
on um more mood stabilizers
and his akathesia which is actually
a fairly common side effect to psych
meds
his academia got way worse and for the
last
two years we've been bouncing from
doctor to doctor
um and for a while his academia was
misdiagnosed
so it took about it took until august
this summer to actually diagnose him
with acathelia
which is a side effect of a medication
but he was bounced from you know
bipolar depression one person diagnosed
him with schizophrenia
and it was like he's just not he's in
pain because of these
medications so he went to
this is in the news too um we made kind
of a family decision
like these medications are harming you
you need to get off of them
but you can't seem to without this
horrible
withdrawal and worsening acathelia so
rehab so he went to rehab in the states
and they that was on the eastern
seaboard isn't that right
he um it was terrible he ended up
there for i believe he was there
september until
november oh my goodness he was never two
months ah a month and a half
yeah oh i see right okay yeah or
two months it's definitely september
till november 2019
and he ended up on more medication
coming out and in worse shape
um and so he went home and tried
titrating down again
and again ended up in such a this
acathesia was so bad
acatheia makes people suicidal it's this
crawling feeling
that's so bad you can see people on
youtube
trying to describe it it's a crawling
sensation that makes you not want to
stop
moving and so it's commonly misdiagnosed
as schizophrenia because
they don't know what it is um and in
order to treat schizophrenia you get put
on psych meds and that causes
worsening akathisia so he was in
he we uh he was in a hospital in
toronto he got back from the first rehab
center
and then his academia got worse when he
tried to get off these medications plus
they had added in
two more so he was in worse shape so
we hospitalized him because we were
worried about
his safety um and when you were worried
that he would injure himself that he
would try that he would hurt himself
and he was worried right like really
oh yeah it was really bad and this is
not like this isn't him right
he's never had that kind of tendency not
even in
in the least so we're like something
this is really bad
so he was hospitalized here in a public
hospital
and they diagnosed him with
schizophrenia
and doubled some of the medications and
so my family was there and at this point
my grandparents had flown over my uncle
had flown over
and we were going the medications are
making him sick
get him off of them how do we get him
off of them and the hospital
here said it's schizophrenia
we should do ect
ect oh my god yeah and he's there
so their entire position is that he has
a psychiatric condition
that they need to trade with drugs your
entire position is
that he has had psychiatric side effects
from being given drugs he should not be
on
and the solution is to get him off the
drugs not to be giving him
but you're at total cross purposes
it was so bad and that like i can
remember one of the conversations we had
with this psychiatrist because he goes
well we think it's schizophrenia
and i was like these symptoms didn't
even start until he started the
medications
okay so you're telling me like a mid 50
year old man with no previous symptoms
of schizophrenia suddenly gets
schizophrenia
which doesn't generally it generally
happens late
teens for men it's not like we're
uneducated in these things right
i was like how about you remove the meds
and just see if it's a side effect
given the fact it could be and he they
wouldn't listen to us
so we called this is
my mom this was just i was worried my
mom was gonna get sick again i was like
i don't know what causes cancer i've
been wondering what's been going on for
your mum during this whole period during
that whole period in 2019.
back to that she she'd had the surgery
and then she obviously she had those
terrible problems with lymphatic
drainage okay so she had the surgery
and then they nicked a lymph duct
and so over the next month it was like
why isn't mom healing why isn't mom
healing
and she ended up emer in emergency about
six weeks after the first surgery
and in canada like we couldn't we had to
wait an emergency to see somebody even
though she just had the surgery
um and then she was in the hospital
for a month um she couldn't eat anything
so she was on
tpn she lost a whole bunch of weight
because she wasn't absorbing any
nutrients
and it was just it was like a horror
movie like every day was like a horror
movie and they're like we don't know
what to do we can't find the leak
um and so we ended up
thank goodness we had have money because
we stayed there and they couldn't fix it
they couldn't fix it
um and we ended up flying down to
um flying down to the states and then
they did a surgery where they went in to
try and find the leak
and they couldn't find it so they
injected this poppy seed dye
that sometimes works and it sealed the
leak
and then she recovered in like you know
not psychologically because she was
traumatizing but she recovered
like in days as soon as the leak stopped
um but at that point so that was august
2019 and that but
that's when your dad's starting to be in
real trouble yeah so he was acatheisic
like
crazy we didn't really understand what
was going on because it's like dad why
are you so
well suicidal and uncomfortable why
can't you sit down
things are okay now and it was because
you mean he would literally be unable to
just sit in an armchair and
with a glass in his hand and just have a
kind of conversation where he's just
sitting still and focusing yeah that
couldn't happen no
he was pacing he was just pacing it was
it was like as bad as the bad videos of
people on youtube look
at the doctor saying this is
nothing this is a psychiatric condition
this is a kind of grief response
was that the theory as well no
no no no it was really like they were
looking back on the
14 years of antidepressants and saying
that this is a re-emergence of
depression
um exacerbated by the stress
uh but it had it didn't have the same
symptoms at all right
he was never like his depression was
like walking through tar
right like he could sit on the couch
he's he napped all the time it was like
a heavy tar it wasn't
agitated panic yeah so
so he's in this hospital in toronto and
they they said we can't get him off the
medications because he needs to be
sedated
because he's so agitated because so that
it increased everything
and at this point he was he had this
sensation to move but he was so sedated
that he couldn't move very well
and i couldn't communicate with him like
my family and i couldn't communicate
with him in this hospital very well
and they wanted to do ect for
schizophrenia and so we started
calling kind of rehab clinics
um around the world we we contacted 57
places my husband and i because at this
point my mom
like i said i was worried the stress was
going to make her ill and it was
too much and so we wrote down all the
rehab centers we could write down
called them and explained what was going
on and said he's on too many medications
he's having these side effects
can you get rid of them can you get rid
of them
and everyone we called except for two
places said
no we have to stabilize him first
and i was like the only thing these
places used to stabilize people are like
antipsychotics or benzodiazepines and
we're like
those are the problems what do we do so
this
one this sounds absolutely insane but
this one place in russia
knew who dad was and was like yeah we do
we do
detoxes
[Music]
i didn't explain at that point because
we also didn't know we didn't know what
was going on we're like this could go
we don't we can't handle the media at
the moment
on top of dealing with whatever the hell
is going on
um so no we we didn't tell anyone who
they were until we'd had a number of
conversations but sorry there were three
places there was a place in israel a
place in serbia and a place
in russia and israel has a very similar
medical system to like a north american
medical system
so when we talked to them a number of
times after we got past
the money they said no we'd have to
stabilize him first but don't worry we
can do that
but we'd already tried a number of
psychiatrists in canada and a rehab
center
in the u.s and a hospital in canada and
no one had been able to stabilize him
because it was akathesia so
we went to russia every like my whole
family
like all my my aunts and my uncle and my
grandparents
they all flew down over christmas my dad
was in the hospital over christmas
in 2019 and and we talked to these guys
in russia and we said look he can't
wean down these medications are killing
him
we could do a detox these guys say they
could do it
but it's going to be you know it's in
russia first of all
um it's got to be dangerous because no
one else will do it
so what do we do because and so my
family
agreed okay let's give it a shot
no at that point we'd tried a number of
things
like you know we got we got to the point
especially when we went to the rehab
center in the states because that was a
high
up i wasn't up there rehab center um and
when that just made him worse
we were like oh well what do we do how
do we get him off these things do we
just do it ourselves
do we just like keep him safe but he was
in so much
pain from this akathesia that it's like
this isn't
fair somebody who's like this should be
like i can understand why they would
sedate people because they need to be
calmed down
because it looks like pain or something
so
we know at that point we didn't go to
russia until we were completely out of
options right
and we um we'd hoped that the hospital
in canada would help but then
they suggested keeping him on the meds
and doing ect and it was like
that is not what his brain needs he
doesn't need to be zapped he'll forget
like the side effects you can forget the
last
year or or two and then what if it
doesn't work because it's not going to
because it's side effects
so we went to russia my husband's
russian
and that was the scariest thing i've
ever done
hands down by far and he went
we flew it was like a movie we flew
there on my birthday we got there
and the day we got there they your
husband your child
and your dad is that right and a
security
[Music]
could check in himself
we took yeah we took a private plane
um we took a private plane yeah he was
trying to educate
he was at this point the hospitals he'd
been in
put him on this regiment where it was
like medication every three
hours to try and stabilize them so we
flew with a security guard and a nurse
um to monitor the transfer
who had russian passports so they were
allowed to go because we had to get a
visa over christmas it was like
it was absolutely ridiculous so we get
to russia and they bring us to this
pretty nice hospital where they do
detoxes
um for people on drugs and most of them
are opiate detoxes so this was not a
usual
case um and they do
i guess in at least in eastern europe
the sedated
detoxes are much more common than they
are here
so they use propofol they put you into a
kind of a coma but a sedation and then
wait till the drugs are out of your
system so what they did for dad
at that point he was on a lot of
medication he was way worse than he had
been even in the summer when my mom was
sick
way worse because he couldn't remember
things at that point because of the
medication
so they put him in this propofol oh
so he gets there and when he arrives he
has a fever
and we're like why is he have a fever
and they do a scan and he had pneumonia
in both lungs
so he'd had it i don't know how long
he'd had it because it was
walking pneumonia so maybe he'd been
there for months but
i don't think so because when he got
into the hospital in toronto
he was walking around and he was there
for two weeks
and um at the end when we took him out
he was just in a bed
he didn't have any energy but it was
hard to tell if it was the
pills nice yeah so we got there and then
we didn't get his medical records they
they um
they were not okay with it we had to
sign papers taking full responsibility
of whatever happened
so he was discharged against doctor's
orders
and they were annoyed about it enough
that they wouldn't give us his papers
which is not even legal right you're
supposed to get discharged
it was a complete mass but um i think
they were confused because
whatever was going on with him was very
severe they hadn't seen it before
and they knew who he was so
it was just it was just a mess and
they're like what are you doing you're
going to russia they're just like what
is happening
but we certainly weren't going to keep
him on the drugs and do ect
under a diagnosis of schizophrenia and
he was well enough that he
talked to the psychiatrist and was like
look i'm not having delusions
like i'm not schizophrenic i'm just i i
can't stop moving i have this crawling
sensation
right i have this impact that he wants
to go to russia
yeah he agreed so like we we made sure
because in case something
terrible happened we needed everybody to
be on the same page
so yes yeah it was not that was a really
awful christmas
so so um so everyone was on the same
page we got to russia
they put him in this um detox and then
he ended up
being intubated which he wasn't supposed
to be
um because of this freaking double
yeah so that was horrible because
that was terrifying so during the um
during the detox they did
something called plasmapheresis which
takes your
blood and cleans it um
which kind of sounds like something out
of science fiction but it's a real thing
and they could test benzodiazepines have
such a long
half-life that there's yeah there's a
theory that maybe some of the withdrawal
is because you still have
benzodiazepines in you
yeah so the plasmaphrasis got rid of
everything and when we got there the
russian doctors who i couldn't
communicate with which was terrifying
but my husband's
husband yeah my husband to me
to my husband to me but that that was
awful
too um i was like how long can how fast
can i learn russian but it's
difficult um so where was i oh yeah when
we got there they said
we think he's been poisoned and that
this was on purpose
the russian doctors they're like we
think someone was doing this on purpose
and i was like no it it's just a whole
it's just what kind of what happens
right
if you have these symptoms you get put
on these other medications
and he just it's really not on purpose
but they're so much more careful in
eastern europe
because there's not as much sounds like
a conspiracy theory but there's not as
much
payment to doctors from pharmaceutical
companies
so doctors don't care if they use
certain meds
so benzodiazepines are almost never
prescribed
and even the other psych meds i'll get
to that
anyway so he does this detox he wakes up
he was sedated with these and intubated
for
9 days
so we just shown up we stayed at a hotel
for a couple of days then got an
airbnb then found us someone to help
with scarlet
because we were spending time at the
hospital
making sure everything was not being
sketchy because it's russia
i don't know it didn't look sketchy but
you want to make sure it's not sketchy
so could you not really tell
initially yeah it looked really good the
hospital we first went to looked um
like decades ahead of the hospitals i've
seen in canada the public ones
it was super clean when you walked in
we got there and you know i can still
communicate with dad he's just in a lot
of pain
we get there and there are these shoe
covers you step
into this machine and it covers your
shoe in plastic automatically yeah
which he'd never seen before and he was
like we got a this is genius
now in the era of covid it might be
genius but um
anyway we uh so
he was relieved too my dad was relieved
when he got there because he was like
he thought he was gonna die he was like
i keep going to hospitals they keep
putting me on more medication i'm
a catheter i can't control it um i'm
gonna die
um so we were at that point and that's
why we ended up in russia
so he does the he does the detox and he
wakes up and he's
in bad shape like
uh mine is delirious delirious but also
not really talking so
when he first consciously
um i thought he was catatonic
so bad really really really bad
when he first woke up he was there a
little bit oh actually when he
first first woke up so this was nine
days after he told me
uh the akathisa is gone
that that was it um the akathis is gone
and i was like okay well thank god for
that because that's what was making him
suicidal
the academies is gone um and we couldn't
it was a hospital so we were visiting
hours so we couldn't stay
we came the next day and then he wasn't
responding he was catatonic
and i went to the i couldn't communicate
with doctors i went to the doctors and i
was like he needs
it's like he needs to be stabilized but
don't use
you know this array of medication but
something is really wrong
what's happening what's going on um and
because
realistically these guys hadn't really
done detoxes from a whole bunch of psych
meds they were
used to dealing with people on opiates
realistically
yeah um anyway so he was
he was catatonic and then he was
delirious
so um we came in the next day and
he thought my husband was his old
roommate
yeah who died
oh it was horrible so he
yeah so i was like you know this is a
huge problem
he needs to they're not he's not being
something's wrong and he's not being
taken care of
anyway so the people
yeah like i lost i've got a whole bunch
of hair extensions in this is not this
is not all me but yeah i've never been
that stressed my entire life and my
husband
obviously we'd brought dad here and
was like what did the detox do it was it
too hard on his brain
like um it looked like it was going to
take him like two years to recover
if he was going to recover it was it was
really bad and so he got transferred to
a
reanimatology clinic um which is for
people with
severe like head trauma basically
three hours north of moscow
a public russian hospital and
and
[Applause]
yeah so at that point i was like we have
he must have been freaking out
and this isn't just like i was like the
entire
i'm if this goes badly because
the entire world is going to blame me
because who brings somebody to detox
first of all from these medications
in russia i was like this is really bad
plus
more importantly this is my dad and this
isn't fair like what's
this isn't fair he's been injured by
medication
that he was put on um so we get to the
reaganomatology clinic
and and the re the head doctor
andre so i couldn't even go inside i was
in the car and i was
like green and nauseous and i was just
like he's not gonna remember this like
andre you go
because i can't talk to anyone i'm just
gonna yell at people
right at that point i was just going in
and yelling at people and i was like i
can't
just go into this and yell at someone in
english it's not helpful
so he went in and he came out and he was
green
and i was like what did they say and he
said that he'd explained why we'd come
that he was being put on too many
medications back home
and that they wouldn't remove them and
he was going to die
and we brought him here and the head
nurse had said oh so you've brought him
here so we can finish the job
and so we went home that day and
you know that was not a good day i had a
like what was that it was like out of a
movie
it was three hours north of moscow
so you had to drive in moscow winter up
there which is insane
uh it had a guarded fence around it
um it was like soviet era hospital from
a movie
it was a huge center and it was full of
really thank god really really really
really skilled
doctors so it
i went the next day and dad was back
whatever they had done had just so i i
got there
and he he hadn't been moving right
he sits up and he looks at me and he
goes you are in so much trouble
and i was like dad
dad um and he he was really confused by
that response because he's like i'm just
yeah i'm just mad at you and you're just
like
happy to see me and so we explained
because he was still pretty out of it
um we explained you know he couldn't
even remember getting on the plane
he couldn't remember getting on the
plane to go to russia so i
remember the entire hospital in um
toronto yeah so he went from like
early december to waking up in a russian
hospital
jeez i know it doesn't it's absolutely
absurd
and the degree of the detox clinic
so he's gone he's lost everything like a
month
and a half yeah a month and a half yeah
yeah and i think that was because
so he was a cathedral at the beginning
of december
um hold on i'm just gonna close this
door
um anyway and then when he went
into this hospital in toronto they had
literally doubled some of the
medications he was on
um to stabilize him and
and then he didn't remember anything
after that but what have they done in
the public hospital in russia
so they had they had given him when i
looked at the list because i was like
did they give him a benzodiazepine
like what exactly is going on here
um and they had given him a whole bunch
of
really low dose kind of everything but
most importantly from what we learned um
he was on using dextor
which is something they use for they use
it for surgery
to put it's kind of like proper fall
they use it
to sedate people who are in a lot of
pain or for surgery
and to calm people down but it's not a
benzodiazepine
or an antipsychotic or one of these
sedative drugs
it's called dextor dexmetadine i think
in um
in the us uh and
so he was he had this iv of dextor
um and then they'd they added in a whole
bunch of vitamins like they just threw
everything at him to try and get him to
stabilize but they didn't use
benzodiazepines which is yeah at the
time which is what we were concerned
about
um and over the next
you he was like okay get me out of here
like right now and i
oh because we had to go the stupid
hospital it was
there was no in russia you can bribe
people and it's a bit more loose with
rules
and this hospital was like soviet era
there was no
staying over the time limit like it
didn't matter who you are
what you were offering um so there were
two hours of visiting
there two hours of visiting hours um a
day so we drove three hours there
uh to visit and then three hours home
and
over the next uh
i can't remember exactly he was in there
for i believe
eight days it wasn't very long thinking
back on it given the state he was in
but he every day was get me out of here
get me out of here and it was like well
dad you have to be able to walk
you have to because you can walk at this
point
no and we don't know like why
exactly
and even the people who done the detox
were like
this isn't you know we don't know and
they had they were
they had good doctors but no one could
explain why what had happened exactly
so
that's not exactly true the head
psychiatrist at this reanimatology
clinic
they did mris and ct scans to try and
figure out what was going on
see if there's brain damage or anything
and they looked at the mri and they said
oh he has damage from the ssris
and i was like what and they're like
yeah he has brain changes from the ssris
because he was on the ssris for so long
and i was like okay whatever like i kind
of just ignored that
um that comes into play a little bit
later
so they did see brain changes they
didn't say brain damage they said brain
changes
but they couldn't really identify what
was going on through scans which was
good
like nothing's really wrong they said
that there was a bit of ischemic damage
but it looked old so it really wasn't
clear
what had happened um and so over the
next
eight days he went from sitting up in
bed
to like shuffling to walking to
basically running down the halls and he
was like i'm getting out of here
he got off of the deck store in a week
and then when we left when we left
that place we drove so then he was going
to the actual rehab center
not that he was a rehab patient but they
did neurological rehab as well
so and we had no we couldn't bring him
home he needed too much care
um he was still like not
not well when we brought him out of that
hospital he could barely walk he
couldn't he didn't really understand
where his feet were
he said he's like i'm blind like i'm i'm
blind
with my feet so he'd hit his feet on
things
um he forgot how to type
so he put his hands on the keyboard and
he's like it's not there i don't know
how to type
and we're just like jesus this is not
good like
this is really not good um and so he
went
and stayed at the rehab center which we
you know
no this was still in russia this is the
israelite would organize the detox
so the first deal
yeah location number three the the for
the deal was he does the detox in a
hospital and he moves to the rehab
center
the the re-entomatology clinic was not
supposed to happen he was not supposed
to understand it
yes exactly so he's there um
and we i was carefully met
monitoring the medication because i was
like i don't want
i know that these medications make him
sick so like remove everything that's
not
you know he was on proton pump
inhibitors they'd added in a whole bunch
of things and i was like he doesn't
need a whole bunch of this stuff what
are you trying to do is get him off
and so that was annoying but he ended up
on and here's where things get tricky so
he ended up
on a very very low dose of an
antipsychotic
um to stabilize um
and a very low dose of an antidepressant
where
and we thought okay these are like tiny
amounts
if that's what he needs to be stable we
can get rid of those later when we're at
home like whatever
so he's doing pretty good he's getting
better and better we're going for walks
one of his friends
flew out got a visa flew out and stayed
with him like
all day because so that someone was
there with him we
we talked to the rehab center they were
really
they took a huge risk bringing him in
there and they were really helpful with
letting people
stay and visit but he was like i want to
go home this is russia this is like
scary um and we wanted to go home and we
thought okay we'll go to florida
because he's not i didn't want to bring
him back to toronto
with mom because it was still too much
work taking care of him
like he needed nurses and things so we
went to
florida and then my brother came to
visit
and was like oh my god you know dad's
better like a lot better
so this had been a month it was horrible
wake up in the
read the morning send some emails was it
that level of function or not really
no he was staying in bed until
mid-afternoon
but then he'd get up and swim
he was barbecuing right so
but he was like kind of quieter than
than normal and a little bit slower than
he should be
yeah and muted yeah and i was like okay
well
he'll i'm more comfortable that he'll
recover now but
something's a bit off so we're there for
a week and a half
and the akathesia comes back and we're
like oh gosh
oh god it was so it was so awful he uh
yeah he called me and he's he's like i'm
you know it's
the zachary's about is back i'm suicidal
again and it was just like
what is going on so we thought it was
yeah after all that yeah
and it was like why it was gone it was
gone nine days after all the medications
left
like it just started to like what what's
going on and i thought
it's the medications it's got to be the
medications
but we were also getting information
from doctors that this could be like
protracted benzodiazepine withdrawal
that just popped up now
so yeah it wasn't
it turns out it was a catheter from the
medication but um
we didn't know that and
so at that point we're like well what do
we do we've already called at the
hospitals in the
the us and if we bring him there when
he's a cathedral they're going to put
him on meds they've already they've
straight up told us that
it's like we're not going back to russia
thanks
um i was like you know what do we do now
so we thought maybe it'll just go away
maybe this is protracted benzodiazepine
withdrawal and it'll just go away
so we stayed with him my grandparents
came down
um and we stayed with him and
for months and the academia got worse
and it got worse and cognitively he was
getting clearer
but he was in a lot of pain so it's
numbness on his left side
this inability to sit down and lay down
this urge to walk around and this
suicidality from this crawling sensation
uh and super super low blood pressure
so he whenever he stand up he he'd black
out
anyway so we contacted this that clinic
in
serbia oh one of the doctors from serbia
had flown out
when dad was in the re animatology
clinic because we had
wanted to obviously wanted a second
opinion we're like what are these people
doing we need uh we need someone who
knows what they're doing here just to
check on them
and he'd come and he and he came this
actually made us feel
way better he came and said this is good
he's doing well
and we're like oh wow thank god for that
so we'd had like an outside
outside source check on these guys
because at that point we were like these
guys don't know what they're doing
um anyway so we were in contact with the
serbian clinic and this was
like top of the world private hospital
where a lot of people from mid the
middle east go to
[Music]
shine
so we talked about this we talked to
this doctor
and he said you know you should come to
this
neuro rehab clinic we do we deal with
stuff i've dealt with this stuff before
i've dealt with benzo withdrawal
um and his akathisa he didn't go off of
these medications because well
they were such a small amount nobody
knew that they could cause such severe
responses
so we ended up it got to the bat it got
so bad that he was a danger to himself
and my family couldn't handle it anymore
it was like my grandparents were there
helping take care of them and it was
just like
it was way too much so we went to serbia
too
you may much we were at it so this is at
the same time
we flew there late late february
covet happened in march so
like everything shut down march april so
he we had rented a house
and we're staying with him taking care
of him
from in which city um
palm beach okay go ahead
yeah kind of relax and heal
yes um and then covert hit and then we
were taking care of
like my family my grandparents
my dad in this covid mess i was like oh
my god
this is a disaster so anyway months
passed like
horrible months passed he's so you were
all in this house
and he's getting worse and we have no
idea why
so his symptoms are way worse in the
morning than they are in the evening so
in the evening he'd actually be pretty
good
it was weird it would like he'd do he'd
do a whole bunch of swimming he'd do
some weights
even in his horrible state he'd do this
stuff and then by like 5
30 he could sit down and have dinner and
by 9 pm we'd watch tv and he'd be laying
on the couch watching tv
and he had a bit of a sense of humor it
was absolutely absurd
and then it'd be like the morning
is gonna happen again like what is going
on
he was like how much am i contributing
like is this in my head just we had no
idea what was going on
so we went to serbia and we get to
serbia and you probably saw the podcast
dad and i did together
um so they put him in under propofol
again
because he was so anxious and of course
he's like i'm back in eastern europe
i'm never gonna see my wife never gonna
go home
like i'm doomed is he articulating all
of these things
yeah he was doing better like at that
point for
he wasn't less he wasn't in a better
place but at least he was more
cognitively
there but
worst case for sure um although it
wasn't unreasonable given what had
happened
so so they seemed to stabilize him they
did this proper fall asleep which seemed
to help
and we figured maybe he wasn't sleeping
right because some people go into benzo
withdrawal and they can't sleep
so we're like i don't know what happened
but thank god he's back although he was
a little like
honestly i would say stoned he seemed
kind of stoned
but i was like i don't care he's at
least he's relaxed
thank goodness um and then about
three weeks later the akathisa came back
and the doctor there was like
what is going on and so that's
where he was diagnosed with akathesia
and that doctor
said i can't help because i can't use
any medication to help him
it's the medications causing these
problems
and there isn't anything i can do and
um at that point well we were like
well at least that makes sense right
it's not in his head
it's a side effect um and they ended up
using they ended up using a
an a partial opiate
um because so this is something that
it's been difficult to know how much of
this to talk about
and how much of it not to talk about
because since i we put out
a video saying hey you know dad's in
rehab this is what's going on because
people are going to find out anyway
yeah um yeah that was september 2019
yeah and
because we've always been pretty honest
about what's going on and it was like
he's writing these self-help books he's
having a hard time like we can't
cut it's worse if we kind of keep that
hidden so we'd been
and it was so much to bear that
telling keeping people updated when he
just disappeared was
was um ideal but the problem with that
is
i've had probably 3 000 people email me
asking how dad's got his acathesia under
control
because there are people who are
suicidal living daily with academia
being treated with psych meds and that
are probably
worsening the symptoms because apathy is
just so poorly understood
so anyway so what he did what he did was
he
started using uh suboxone which doesn't
it's like it's a partial opiate and
technically they use it
to treat people who are addicted to
opiates to get them off of it
um which obviously wasn't his problem
but it also has
calming properties and it's used to
treat acathelia
yeah so if you there are studies online
too if you find someone who really knows
what they're doing
um they can safely use opiates to treat
acathesia
because you can't use any of the other
sedating drugs
like any of the psych meds can trigger
it ssris snris
antipsychotics really really can
benzodiazepines
like like he tried all of them so um the
serbian clinic had tried
everything it was insane they tried
everything because they had stabilized
him initially
but it turns out akathis is a little bit
more complicated
it's delayed so it doesn't happen
necessarily it doesn't necessarily
happen as soon as you take the
medication
for my dad it happens three weeks later
so that that's why he kept getting
better and then
the academia would come back the
academic would come back
so um so when we're in serbia for three
months trying to stabilize them because
this doctor
is just like i can't believe this
because it's fairly rare and his was so
severe that it was
very rare um and he so we ended up
flying
him home um i i came home actually to
organize the transfer
my husband stayed there with him um
we got kovid when we were there that's
not even like that yes
that's ice
[Music]
i don't know where we caught it from but
um so when we got to serbia
serbia is interesting it was completely
open
completely open so going from the states
to serbia i was like whoa
and the government had said there are no
covid cases there
i remember when i said i had that sort
of golden side
yeah and we were so not like because my
dad was we weren't concerned
covid was like the least on our list of
problems
um so anyway then
then elections happened there were and
then they shut down the country like
days after elections they're like oh
covet is everywhere
um mandatory quarantine and then there
were riots
um my nanny at that point got hit
on the outskirt of a cr outskirt of a
crowd with tear gas
um because of the riots because people
were like hey you said there was no
coved
and now it's everywhere and you just
like their elections are
a little off so so we
we all it was either quarantine at home
and not see dad at all or quarantine in
the hospital
and at this point yeah
so i was like no freaking way are we
doing that so we stayed
in a room in the hospital and 11 days
into quarantine
my daughter probably was the first one
to get
symptoms she just had an upset stomach
and then my nanny
had an upset stomach and then i had an
upset stomach but it was like whatever
it's like an upset stomach it's not that
bad
so quarantine was over this is 14 days
we moved back home
um and as soon as we got home the
hospital is like
jordan has we tested him because they're
testing all the time
jordan has covid and we're still all
sick
right but we're like no freaking way
like are you kidding me
so we all got coveted including my nanny
everyone at the hospital got coveted um
igor the head guy of the hospital he'd
already had kovid
like a lot of people had had antibodies
already there
um and then they treated dad
preemptively so you can take like some
of the protocols in vial
involve antibiotics and steroids
preemptively
which i wasn't a huge fan of because my
dad doesn't react well to medication and
i was like why don't you wait for the
symptoms
before you put him on medication because
he doesn't react well
um so they ended up using
so we weren't allowed to go visit him
because he was in like we weren't
allowed to go visit him
for five days and i got there and he was
in the worst shape like i
he was just he was so agitated it was
hard to believe
and and give an example
facial moaning like um
the easiest way honestly there are
videos of people with acatheia on
youtube it looks like so it was bad and
everyone in the hospital was freaked out
um and
i was like there's because he was way
worse than he was a week ago
um and i was like oh my god are they
using fluoroquinolones
because at this point i've i've read so
much on this stuff it's
absolutely absurd and i know that
there's a class of antibiotics that
you're not supposed to give to people
who are in benzo withdrawal um
called fluoroquinolones and i was like
please like please let them not be using
fluoroquinolones
turns out they were using
fluoroquinolones and the site the
interaction is not very well
read well known it's just absurd that
these things kept happening
they don't use fluoroquinolones as much
in the states because they have side
effects
um people can get like poisoned from
them they're they're just a
intense class of antibiotics so he turns
out he was on fluoroquinolones and i
flipped and was like we're pulling him
out now even though it wasn't safe
because
he was a catheter now unless you stop
the fluoroquinolones
like now um and andre talked to the head
doctor
who was also really stressed out at this
point because it's like
what am i doing wrong i've tried
everything and he was a really good guy
he's probably the best doctor i've met
um but he was super stressed out he was
pissed off being questioned
um but he did drop the fluoroquinolones
and dad got a lot better really quickly
so but so this was after we recorded
this freaking podcast being like hey i'm
stably doing better and then got like
covet and acadia and i was like i was
like oh my god this again
so anyway he's after that
he was put on suboxone the suboxone
helped a lot
with the akathesia but it was still kind
of there we go home
so september so he's home finally
um we'd left in january september we
hadn't been home for nine months
yeah um he's home so he hasn't seen your
mom in nine months
mom came mom came to florida to visit um
and then went home and we're trying to
keep her stress levels very low because
of how sick she was
it was just like he didn't want you know
it was better for her to not see this um
so she came to visit in florida and she
also came
this was so this was really hard on dad
this was really hard on everybody
uh she came to serbia and
literally the day after she arrived
um they locked everything down and the
head of the hospital said we're going
into quarantine and you should go home
because you've had cancer you're at a
high higher risk
you should go home and we were i was so
angry
because i was like dad was so
looking forward to seeing her and then
it was like you got to go home
two days um but
we did end up getting kovid and she
didn't
so he was probably right about that
to be honest yeah um at the time it
didn't feel good but
we did end up getting coveted and she
didn't so um
so anyway we get home and he's doing
like he's still not in good shape he's
waking up late
he's and he's a cathedral so it's the
pacing the uncomfortable
yeah numbness burning sensations like
really
bad neurological stuff um
yeah yeah so he goes to a psychiatrist
and the psychiatrist puts him on an
antipsychotic
and i go my my husband and i
had a he made a had a fit right we were
like we have seen this happen a whole
bunch of times he was diagnosed with
that catheter
in three weeks we're going to be totally
um yeah
yeah and people because they hadn't
it because everyone was completely
stressed out and
people here hadn't seen what was going
on
they were kind of like just take a break
guys you need to take a break
which was true because
yeah um so we're like okay
we'll take a break maybe this will work
like you know just like maybe it'll work
because
initially it works he's feeling better
so it works so then they add in an
antidepressant
three weeks later the it was so bad
again it was
it was like 12 hours of akathesia um
and and so um andre and i
got got involved again and said that
psychiatrist is fight oh
first what happened is we called the our
family doctor
and said he's acatheisic again the
psychiatrist isn't listening
he's treating him for bipolar it's
making the akathisa worse
can we have a referral to another
psychiatrist
and our doctor said no just like leave
it alone just let them do it
and we were like okay so we had to
switch gps
so then at that point
that was complete yes 100 but
where is
oh no i've been problematic for a while
right this is this is not new i've i'm
i'm pretty pushy when i think something
is wrong and because of
because i've had issues with an
autoimmune disorder that i've managed to
get under control with an absolutely
absurd diet
i've had choices i've had to be pretty
pushy um
i've had to be pretty
um no it did change when we were in
serbia it got it expanded a bit a little
bit he had
like fruits and things it didn't seem to
make much
difference like he he was just so
screwed
um i'll get to the diet in a sec let me
let me wrap it
just up a new family yeah so we got a
new family gp
we got we're like that's it the meds
have to go so when he came back from
serbia he was on the suboxone and he was
also on a sleeping pill to help him
sleep at night
and at this point we're like everything
has to go because it turns out you can
get academia from like every
everything and sleeping pills like
antipsychotics
antidepressants benzodiazepines opiates
much much rarer
but um those ones so we're like okay
maybe when he came back from serbia
because he was still on the sleeping
pill that was giving him this underlying
akathesia and then it was made
worse by these two new other drugs so
anyway
um over the next two week period
uh with this other gp everything was
removed except for suboxone
um and he slowly got better but it was
not fast and it was really
quite bad but it was instead of 12 hours
it was eight hours and then it was like
six hours but even a minute of this
akathisia
makes people insane because it's so
uncomfortable so it was still like
hours a day and he'd go to bed and he'd
be like oh my god i feel normal it's
gonna happen again in the morning
so at that point i went on this rampage
and i
contacted i'd done this before but i did
a new search now that i knew that we
were looking for academia
to try and find academia experts and i
found one in vancouver
and
because of benzodiazepine withdrawal not
a catheter because of psych meds
which is what it was so anyway so we do
a whole bun i do a whole bunch of
consultations with
i talked to five different specialists
acatheisia specialists
um and tell them the whole story i had
typed up like
12 pages of medical notes with
everything that had happened sent them
all over to these academic specialists
and just like
plus i was getting thousands of emails
from people telling me what worked for
them
so there's a lot of information and i um
i had dad do a couple of consults with
these doctors and we finally found the
zachathisa specialist who goes
so it turns out people who take ssris
for a very very long time especially if
it's at a high dose
if they stop taking it not only can they
have protracted withdrawal
which causes insomnia
impending doom panic
people usually treat that by going sugar
free and low-carb
because they're so sensitive their brain
is so sensitive that it reacts to
um chemicals light uh
smell and high carbs like sugar
and so i we thought okay that maybe
that's why when we went low carb because
we were eating meat
right because everything else was
causing this horrible impending doom
it was like maybe that was ssri
withdrawal
and so this the psychiatrist said
that's that's from the ssri withdrawal
and the interesting thing is
i had that similar so i went on this
meat diet
and i stopped taking ssris that i've
been taking for 11 years
and i had these reactions with carbs
that were just absolutely
horribly absurd and they don't happen
anymore
so i still have an autoimmune disorder
that i have to deal with but these
impending doom insomnia reactions
stopped happening
and a lot of people i've talked to who
do this
meat diet are getting off of meds
and so i think it must have something to
do with that and according to this
psychiatrist you can go on a low-carb
diet to help
ameliorate some of these psych side
effects so apparently people who are on
ssris for a long time
if they start up again on a
benzodiazepine
or an antipsychotic they're way more
likely to get acatheia
than the general public
so he looked at the case and he said yep
he took those
for 14 years he went off and then when
he went back on they caused
going up and everything caused akathisia
and he's been on
he was on psych meds for the whole year
so that's the akathisa
and what you have to do he's like the
opiates help
so just stay on that get off of
everything else and wait
and it was just like what and this guy
was he just moved he'd moved to toronto
five month um
not toronto just outside of toronto five
months ago
so he's just new here i think he's from
australia
and he's an act he's like one of the top
academia specialists in the world
um and he explained everything and so
now
dad is once all the antipsychotic stuff
were gone um and he started
he's mad at the academia's lifted he
hasn't been acatheisic now for a number
of weeks which is the first time that's
happened
he's only on suboxone he's gone he's cut
it down in half
right so it's going away he only needed
it because of this
akathisia covering the symptoms um and
so
it's over now like he's uh he's anxious
he's very prone to stress he's got ptsd
a hundred percent from the last number
of years
um but we know that the acathesis is
caused by any medication
basically that's a psych med and it's
gone now
but holy was that
that was a bad year so we had christmas
this year
and he opened all his gifts from last
christmas
it's been like it was it was just absurd
we're just like how the hell did that
happen
but uh we have a great gp now
who completely understands what's going
on who who
who actually knew about akathesia he was
like why was he put on an anti-psychotic
if he has academia
and i was like i don't know that's what
i've been saying
um so we've got a great gp and
he's doing he just he just released a
podcast with matthew mcconaughey
so he's still not he still has to
recover he's walking a lot
but he's like the acathesis is not there
but he can get up in the morning yeah
yeah he's he's getting up at eight
then he's having a song he found
we found saunas okay so when i when i
talked to this
psychiatrist and he said this ssri
withdrawal can have this impending doom
panic i was like oh i had that for like
two years
after i stopped ssris but i had a baby
and i was so convinced to control this
without meds
and i was kind i was like something
makes me feel weird with those i don't
want to take those
um so i had it for two years and one of
the things that really helped was
infrared saunas
no idea why but getting in there and
sweating
made a massive difference if i could do
that
and my mom built an infrared sauna in
the basement
so dad goes into the infrared sauna in
the morning and then he eats
then he walks for like 10 kilometers
oh wow yeah 10 to 15. he's walking a ton
so
somebody walks with him every day um and
then in the afternoon he works and
so and his book is coming out in march
and
i think he's going to recover fully i
think from
my experience which was not like his i
never had
like he had it so bad the akathesian
stuff but from my experience it took
a couple of years to recover from all
the medication i was on
i think that he'd say the book coming
out by the
end yeah i mean
oh yeah like we had a call with a
publisher when we were in russia
and at that point my dad was like i'm
never getting better just publish it
and i was like am i gonna have to like
it's not even done like
what do we do um but he worked on it
through this akathisia
period he worked on it and finished the
book edited it
did the audiobook he did
while he was in florida so
he was editing in florida and serbia
um he'd finished right i think he
finished writing in florida
editing in serbia and then he did the
audio book in december
um right at the right when we solidified
that this was acatheisia caused by it
wasn't just caused by benzodiazepines it
was caused by anything
yeah and yeah so um he's doing
way better but i mean it's been hard on
my family
like they were they were anxious about
this interview
because they're like what's it gonna
cause and we figured
because he has his book coming out in
march we don't want
the questions surrounding the book
release to be
all health focused
there's been like hints of you know
there was a podcast and things so people
are kind of up to date
but um we figured what kind of feedback
have you had
like horribly negative um
negative like um yeah it's been pretty
hard on me
uh because we well we went to russia and
it was like you brought you know your
i get a lot of people being like you're
killing your dad you're killing your dad
with your diet and you're killing your
dad you know bringing him to russia
it's trolls um but
it's real it was really hard especially
when i was like in russia being like
they were all attacking you for being in
russia taking them to russia
yeah because they didn't understand
right and they didn't know oh we tried a
whole bunch of hospitals we called
57 of them right we went to one of the
top rehab centers
in the states we went to a hospital in
canada like they did they were just like
you just brought them to russia
which like yeah i get it and then people
don't care if you're
removed but um it's been hard so part of
the reason
yeah it's been really hard and of course
there's a lot of there's a lot of
support too
it's like jordan's back like thanks for
the help there
um but you always see the negative
more and it's pretty easy to make it a
negative story because i already have
this weird
you only eat meat diet um although i was
really using that to treat health secret
serious health problems and so is dad
it's not like i force-feed him
right it's up to him what he does but um
it's an easy story to twist because it's
like all meat diet
goes to russia for a detox that you're
not supposed to do on these medications
i get it but it has been hard because of
how stressful the year's been anyway
[Music]
we're good now but it's been hard
throughout the whole thing because
for part of it part of it they like i we
had certain family members that were
like it does look like an underlying
problem he was depressed it is an
underlying problem
and so there were times when it was just
me being like
this is medication those are side
effects
but then all the doctors are also saying
it's an underlying problem
and you put any family under a whole
bunch of stress
and people snap so now it's like things
are so much better now
everyone is like thankful and happy and
just recovering because we are like
weeks into finally figuring out what the
issue was if it had been as simple as
benzodiazepine withdrawal
i think he would have been better in
march exactly
because they stabilized him on this it
was such a low dose too
like it's i hadn't
nobody had any idea including the
doctors and
that these kind of small amounts can
trigger
such terrible symptoms with people and
then i've had so
many people reach out um murtazapine is
the other thing
so eventually suboxone and mirtazapine
and mertaza bean is a medication that's
used to treat acatheisia there are a
whole bunch of medications used to treat
agatha
all of them gave him academia except for
mirtazapine so that's been like
a godsend
what about your mom's health okay
what's her prognosis good she's getting
like
she's not getting like you know you
after you have cancer you have to get
checked every three months and things
yeah those are i think it's six month
points now so she's okay
and she's like she's doing really given
what's happened and how traumatizing
it's been like she's doing really well
so and my brother had a baby like
we've made it through and things are
going to be really good
um but it was a hell of a year i
wouldn't wish this akathesia on
anybody and part of the reasons
i think he'll be doing better like i
think it's going to take him a little
bit of time
but when he's not on any medication and
he's recovered from the damage it's done
yeah he's gonna be on fire i've i'm not
concerned about that
at all he's anxious when am i gonna
recover and all this stuff but like
this is new it's gonna take a while but
i'm i'm
absolutely certain that he's going to be
120 percent extraordinary amount of
responsibility
in terms of making judgment i mean
you've been around the world for a whole
year in the very own countries
[Music]
yeah it was horrible training
yeah i've done because of my experience
being ill
i've done a lot of research but no i
don't have
training i just know like there's this
trust
people have in doctors that i don't have
because doctors are just people
right they make mistakes there are
things that they don't know
i don't i don't trust and from the
reaction i've had to medications the
doctors have said that's not possible
and i've had it i know it so
when i saw how hard it was on my mom and
i was like there
my family had didn't know what to do
other than to leave him in the hospital
for ect
they didn't want to do that they said no
but we don't know what to do
no to that but we don't know what to do
we don't know where to go like what are
the options
and i thought okay i'm i'm in a pretty
good place like
i could handle this for a while i'm
completely burnt out now
um and it was like worse i was hoping it
would be
a smoother ride i was hoping we'd go
there it would go easily
and we'd be back in six months or three
months
um with dad better but like turns out it
took a year
but at least we're here but yeah it was
stressful i definitely do not recommend
any of the last year
no i can well imagine it's an
extraordinary
tale isn't it yeah i wrote it down like
i was keeping notes because i was just
like
this is absolutely absurd
yeah it's an amazing brilliant
um but i think that was incredibly
comprehensive
uh yeah
yeah i'm good okay well thank you thank
you
and yeah
if there's anything else
yep for sure we're just looking we're
looking to
dad was hoping i don't know what the
article is going to be like he's hoping
it's not going to focus
entirely on health i said that i read
the other stories and some of them were
pretty health focused so
we'll see what he says tomorrow because
he's trying to you know
get past this but we thought if people
understood what happened
and the reasoning behind things then we
could just let it be
it's like this happened don't do some of
these things
and if you are on these medications like
especially psych meds
and you're acatheisic and you weren't
before maybe look at the meds right
but people don't know about it and there
are some docs some specialists out there
that can help
if you know what the problem is um
but yeah ideally we'll just leave this
be and then dad can go back to
touring and writing and doing podcasts
and
being controversial and we can not deal
with
uh health for a while it's like my
entire life
but yeah reach out if you have any
questions
thank you very very much hey thank you
bye
you